Sweet,
bubbly baby Jesus.
Ladies and gentlemen,
what the fuck?
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by
[inaudible] where space Squarespace.
If you go to squarespace.com forward slash Joe you can try Squarespace for free.
No credit card needed and build yourself a fucking website son or Gow.
Can't be calling chicks cow or chickson.
Can't really call them galley to,
that's kind of rude anyway,
squarespace.com is the best resource I've ever found online for creating a
really cool looking website very easily.
Any dumdum can do it,
probably even me.
Brian does them.
Every time we do a fucking podcast,
he'll throw a new one up.
fart@cocc.com the machine,
he's creating a machine website right now as we speak.
Yeah.
Okay.
What does it say?
We're going to just kind of create a fucking website.
It's super easy to use.
You can make online stores very easily.
All of it is very easy and this is all stuff that just simply was not available
just a few years ago,
a few years ago,
if you wanted to get a website done,
you either had to hire someone who really knows how to code and do a website or
master one of those,
uh,
um,
kind of complicated programs for creating websites.
But Squarespace and makes it super easy.
I learned html right when it,
right before it got useless.
Ah,
did you learn it?
The little thing Raf,
all that.
I learned how to do it and I learned a few things and then just when they
started saying,
you don't have to do that anymore,
you can just type in the thing.
It'll show up.
It's Kinda dope though.
It's Kinda like,
um,
I mean I,
I've noticed
it's Bert let square per.com
that should so be a website squirt when he done quickly,
quickly,
Brian,
register that scored bird.
Let's squirt burt.com quickly,
quickly go to hover.
Um,
if you go to squarespace.com forward slash Joe and I said,
you can try it out and,
and fuck with it and build a website.
And then if you decide to purchase it,
you use the code Joe Five,
all one word,
j,
o e and then the number five.
And you can save 10% off your first purchase,
a new scent,
excuse me,
save 10% off your first purchase on new accounts,
including monthly and annual plants.
It's really cool website.
Uh,
and if you,
if you're interested in creating your own website,
it really is the way to go.
And you can do it yourself on a budget,
like super easy.
It suites.
We're also brought to you by ting.
Ting is,
I'm a cell phone company that uses the sprint backbone.
They have the same service that sprint has as far as uh,
the signal strength and all that jazz.
But the way they have it set up,
they have no contracts.
You don't have to have a contract and you buy your phone.
And if you decide like,
I don't use this anymore,
you can just quit and cancel it.
You just,
you move on and you're,
you're not connected
to them anymore.
They have the highest level,
uh,
android phones,
including the Samsung Galaxy note to which is this beastly phone that I,
as soon as I have some fucking free time getting one of those.
I use Tang like a mother fucker in Vancouver this weekend.
What's funny is because I had the a t and t uh,
iPhone and the galaxy s three on Ting and my iPhone,
uh,
my calling plans and everything,
how it was set up,
it would have cost me every time I downloaded a photo,
it would probably cost me about $60.
Because you were terrified to use your phone.
Yeah.
You're,
you're like,
please just check.
Give him money.
I had to give him Canadian money to check his email,
check your email,
give me a hundred dollars fuck with your brain,
man.
You let them fuck with your brain when it's $20 or whatever the fuck it is.
You just kind of let it go.
Yeah.
What's funny is
using it for brief amounts of time,
I got like two emails from at and t saying you've already gone over a hundred
dollars in data.
Oh,
it sucks too.
When you sit down and you're sitting at a bar and you're like,
you're like,
you think you're on the Wifi and all of a sudden it just starts pushing all your
Twitter.
You're like,
what the fuck is this?
Yeah,
I do.
You could definitely blow your wad when you're in a foreign country and you
using cell phone,
sir.
And what's cool is ting has a page and see if I can find it for you.
That it just shows you what,
what country,
what the rates are in every country.
And it just works like it's,
this is how much it will cost to check your email.
And it's not like rape.
Uh,
it's not,
they should put that in there as [inaudible].
We're not raping in with the word in there.
It's not great money.
Brian red band.
Yeah.
I mean it was on it on,
it was running ting.
That would be commercial.
Find it that I can look at this,
right?
It's not like rape.
Never.
You never use your never used data plans when you're studying it.
When you're a over abroad,
always use the fucking Wifi at the hotel.
Get all your shit.
Once you get there,
go to Starbucks.
It's really is kind of rude.
Okay.
That's for this fucking well,
no wonder we're the best in the world.
All right,
so check this out.
Receiving and making calls.
If you're in Canada,
15 cents a minute,
that's pretty legit.
You're not usable.
Yeah,
that's reasonable.
It goes this and hand it off.
That's a four.
And a conversation only cost you,
what is it?
60 cents?
Say 15 cents a minute.
But here's the good thing.
Receiving and sending text messages that just literally 0 million cents.
Oh,
that's beautiful.
That's great.
That's how it should be.
All right.
A one megabyte on a t and t,
uh,
with the,
with just a normal calling plan was $15 and 50 cents per megabyte.
That's how much it costs per megabyte.
Ting.
50 cents.
Yeah,
but let's go.
Let's go.
A little fucked up country.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
that's beautiful.
Yeah.
It's calling another country 15 cents a minute.
I mean it's,
it's,
but it just kind of show you what the differences is.
I use both phones in Canada and I bet you my bill on at and t is at least $400 I
bet you my
bill on ting is probably like $7.
I bet you're right.
Well,
the what tings idea was when,
when they first created their company,
they wanted to have,
uh,
an ethical cell phone company.
That's sort of like,
it seems to be their motto.
They want to have cell phones that,
you know are like,
you're not sacrificing the quality of the device or the quality of the service,
but instead of getting locked into some stupid ass contract,
it kind of feels gross.
You don't have to do that.
You leave whenever you want.
They also credit you on unused minutes.
It's beautiful if you use more or less,
rather if you use less than you,
uh,
you had signed up for,
they knock you down to the lower level and they credit you the difference on
your next bill.
Like,
no one's trying to rip you off.
They're just trying to give you really good cell for cell phone service at a
reasonable rate and everybody can be happy instead of being greedy.
Twats everybody literally can be happy.
Um,
they have,
uh,
the HTC one too.
I see you to have that up there.
You see that thing up in the corner?
That's pretty bad ass.
I'm guy had that in Vancouver the other day.
That's these fucking android phone.
Yeah,
he's android phones screens.
This one.
It was like really huge ones.
That cods fun.
Wow.
Yeah.
The HTC one looks pretty sweet.
There's um,
that new Samsung a five g that they,
uh,
just revealed that they're going to have the capability of downloading an entire
movie in one second.
Oh,
shut the fuck up.
Shut the fuck up.
Oh God.
That just scared the shit out of him.
Is that even possible?
Our normal,
our normal Internet can't even do that.
Well,
no,
it's stronger than the normal internet.
You don't understand.
It's like next level shit.
The five g on your cell phone is going to be stronger than the Internet shut.
Oh,
it's going to break the Internet.
That's fucking,
that's when the aliens are coming through.
When you can download a movie in a second,
the aliens will then say,
okay,
this is a strong enough network for us to invade and they're just going to just
hop into the Internet and that's how they're going to get into our world.
Joe,
you're going to be listening to this podcast a couple like two years from now
and just laughing at this because we're like on hg already.
You know what's crazy is if they had put this in during lunch,
tomorrow land and Disney world and they had said it,
it probably wouldn't impress that many people.
But like a jet pack impresses people.
Right.
But this is so next level.
It's so next level.
You know,
back when I had a t one line in my house,
um,
I remember when I had that Brian when I was a quake player.
Yeah.
That was the only 1.5 megs.
That shit was nothing.
It was a whack of dishes you can comparison to now me back down,
I was a goddamn superstar.
You know you've got a t one line,
I don't even know what a t one line is.
It's a fat business internet pipe,
but it's nothing compared to like Verizon fiber optics.
Yes.
Nothing,
nothing.
I mean not even fucking close like these time Warner cable packages we can get
like who knows what kind of just nonsense download speeds there.
They're insane
now you know,
you can get like really powerful Internet that makes a t one line like I had
from like 1998 or something like that.
It makes a t one line looked like a piece of shit.
I the,
we were our tea,
our Internet's fucked up in our neighborhood and they said it's always going to
be that fucked up cause we all share off the same server.
And so until they upgrade.
Wait,
what are you on?
DSL?
Uh,
I don't know.
Yeah,
DSL.
So you don't have cable in your neighborhood like wired cable or charter cable?
We don't have cable.
We have,
well we have direct TV in our house,
but we don't have cable Internet.
Are you sure you don't have cable internet?
You don't fucking know.
Why are we asking?
Hey,
here's what you did.
You find out which cable company is connected to your streets.
So you probably have Warner or charter or something like that.
Then you just call him and go,
Hey,
I need internet.
They'll come to your house and give you the fastest Internet.
Even faster than most.
Like 90% of households are Internet sucks Dick and are rude.
I just told you how to fix it.
Said don't worry about it.
You can get done today.
Okay.
I probably won't get it done today or this week off.
I don't,
I don't live there
anyway.
[inaudible] Dot Com save 25 bucks and that's how you do a commercial debt.
Um,
we're also sponsored by stamps.com if you go to stamps.com and click on,
there's a microphone in the upper right hand corner entering the code word,
j,
r e and he give you a special offer.
What stamps.com is,
first of all,
it's to the company.
If you,
one of the things we see at all of our shows,
I see you fucking Weirdos wearing those kitty cat shirts.
It's like a,
it's an outfit.
You know,
it's like when,
when death squad fans,
when they come to these comedy shows,
all those shows that all those shirts rather than Brian makes,
he makes them himself.
He,
it's his artwork and then he sells them through desk squad.
Dot TV and when you get them delivered,
they come from stamps.com it's way easier than packaging everything and then
going to the post office and it all has to get weighed and then you have to
figure it out and pay.
This way.
You don't have to deal with any of that nonsense.
You printed all up on your computer,
boom.
Slap it on your package,
leave it out for the post man,
and you're golden.
I got certified jet son.
I got a certified letter today in the mail and the mail man had to come to my
door and had to sign for it type thing.
Are you going to jail?
Maybe?
No,
but uh,
uh,
I only had boxers on my fucking Dick was hanging out.
I was asleep because it was like eight in the morning.
I signed for it.
My Dick was like hanging out the boxes.
Didn't realize it happened.
I went to bed at four and you know,
like literally was on three hours sleep.
Thought you were coming on to him and it was like,
all right,
let's fucking do that.
Slammed the door behind him.
I helped me just drops,
dropped to his knees,
stood stuck in your flats at Koc and you're like,
oh,
that's what,
no,
darn it.
It was just out.
I didn't mean that.
That would be great.
Brian.
He's an Asian guy to his.
Yeah.
The other thing for Asian,
if you had to fuck your race,
what would it be?
What if you had a or race,
what would it be for Christ Chrysler?
Would you want a goddamn stamps?
The fuck kind of question is that?
How about just treat them all the same bird?
What did Martin Luther King died for?
Nothing.
You fuck what I'm talking about?
Letting them on a bus when talking about fucking him.
That's the same one of them in your bed.
The same except them are not young Martin
stamps.com like an eight the code where a j.
R.
E you get a special offer.
$110 value,
$55 in postdoc coupons.
Free digital scale that you're not going to use for weed.
Wink,
wink.
Don't wait.
May Weigh your weed out on that,
but do weigh your weed.
Okay.
Especially if you're putting it into something as you're cooking it.
Don't be stupid.
Don't go by eyeball.
I don't know what the fuck you're doing.
Too many people don't.
That's why I'm not,
I'm not eating anybody's cookies.
Are you fucked
crazy.
Oh,
I fucked that kind of putting these cookies.
Yeah.
That Guy Brian had something and I was like,
don't eat it.
And he's like,
I want to eat it,
and I'm like,
you're fucking crazy.
I'm not touching that shit.
This guy gave me so much stuff and I was like,
dude,
I'm only here for seven more hours.
Yeah,
it's a,
Vancouver is such a fascinating place.
Can go drugs like crazy Canadians.
They're better than Americans.
They are.
They're like 20% better there.
Americans,
younger Americans aren't cool as fuck and that the Canadians aren't Douche bags.
I'm just thinking like the overall behavior of the people is is better.
It's because the Chinese are robots in the house.
I think that there's something,
there's so many Chinese people there that was so interesting when that,
well,
we should talk about this then.
Yeah.
That's not why they're so nice.
China's not necessarily known for being nice and I guess you answered my
question of who was fucking first.
Well,
we need to talk about Vancouver because I noticed so much stuff.
I've researched that shit.
Vancouver is amazing.
Anyway,
where were we?
Stamp Talk Com.
Go fuck yourself like yourself,
Jay already.
Codeword J R II.
That's how you save some money.
It's an awesome product.
And,
and again,
it is a product that um,
Brian actually uses so we can talk about it.
All the shit that we talk about in the podcast,
we try,
when we have commercials we try to make,
I mean you've heard it a million times from me before,
listen all the time,
but we try to make sure that nothing we're selling isn't anything that
everything we're selling rather,
uh,
it's something that we would use.
Nothing we're selling is embarrassing.
Nothing we're selling is just bullshit that you're selling just to make money.
And that goes with a on it.
I smoked too much pot before the show my throat,
but it's not even that.
It's my throat.
It's very unprofessional,
these gentlemen.
Anyway,
uh,
on a.com if you haven't been there for awhile,
we added a bunch of different foods,
like a buffalo bars and now we have hemp force bars,
hemp protein bars,
really
delicious and their dance,
these little fucking things.
If you want something to fill you up if you're in between,
that's what I use him for most of the time.
Honestly.
I use him for like if I'm on the golf,
I'm like traveling or something.
Instead of eating a cheeseburger,
I'll eat a cup of those hemp protein bars.
They're little tiny bars and I'm good.
They're just such dense protein.
Um,
we also sell like Blendtec blenders to make smoothies with.
We now have Wallman all almond cashew butter.
We have a bunch of like really healthy cool shit like Himalayan salt and killer
bee honey.
Um,
and as well as a bunch of different fitness equipment.
Do you guys do a bulletproof coffee?
Yeah.
Yeah,
we saw that now dude,
I just had that for the first time this morning.
If people don't know what book proof coffee is,
our good pal Dave Asprey,
who I've been going back and forth with to get him on the podcast.
Again,
we're just trying to figure out a date that works for both of us.
He figured out,
or at least he told us that other people had figured out that there was
something on coffee called Mycotoxins that a lot of folks are not aware of and
they can exist if coffee isn't stored correctly.
If it's under the wrong conditions,
if you know the crop gets infected with this fungus and that is a,
it exists in a lot of coffee.
And one of the things that people associate with coffee,
like with being like there's crash and feeling like shit after it's over,
it may very well be that what you're getting in that experience is the effects
of these mycotoxins,
these,
uh,
these fungal toxins that are on the coffee.
So not all coffee is created equal.
And what Dave Asprey figured out is how to get coffee from a single source,
meaning the people that grow it are the people that pick it or the people that,
that,
that cook it,
you know,
um,
bacon or whatever the fuck that is.
What do they call it when they turn coffee,
they call it,
they don't roast,
bake it roasted.
And when they do it all together,
they control the process and they know that they don't have any of these
mycotoxins on it.
I'm still interested to wonder like what I would like to get somebody from my
Folgers to come in here and be like fuck,
love the guy that I would love to hear what they say about it to hold uses the
wrong company in my opinion.
Like the get a guy who there's the exact same thing.
No,
no but like there,
there are coffee [inaudible] like the dudes,
I got a guy that worked on travel channel till you didn't even stumble with that
work and practice that word for a reason.
But I'm talking about mass market.
Like people like if this is all true,
like somebody that delivers mass amounts of it but you don't want them cause
they're never,
they're never going to be honest.
Starbucks would be a great president.
Starbucks,
they're never going to be honest with you about anything.
You're going to talk to them and they're going to go,
well we don't have those.
Microtoxins you want to talk to a guy who has no affiliation with it?
Not even,
I mean not,
I'm not going to test it.
It is what
you want to do.
You don't want to tell it to anybody,
which you want to do is you want to go to Starbucks,
you want to pick up a bag of coffee and you want to go test it.
Yeah.
Until then everyone's just talking shit.
So I hope Dave Asprey comes on and drop some knowledge on us.
But what I do know is that his his,
which is this combination
of what he calls upgraded coffee,
which is single source coffee when you know it doesn't have any mycotoxins on it
and grass fed butter along with MCT oil and he blends it up in one of those
Blendtec blenders and it's fucking sensational.
That's great.
So good.
If it gives you energy for like a long time.
It's really weird.
It has a much more prolonged effect because of the MCT oil apparently and the
grass fed butter,
like all the richness of it.
It's a slower digesting sort of thing.
A tutor for the first time today and my wife,
my wife,
I pulled it out and I had heard it from here.
They will come to my show in Portland and gave me a box,
a bag,
and I was like,
fucking so pumped you.
I went and bought,
we don't have a coffee maker.
We have that,
you know that?
Click it in the little pods.
I liked it.
I had to go buy a fucking French Press.
I had to grind it up kind of rough and I did it.
It was like,
and my wife and I had it.
I fuck him.
And they said,
you don't eat much.
I fucking ate like a little bit of salmon today.
Some egg whites this morning.
I'm fucking set.
I fucking love that shit and I'm going to buy it.
Well it's,
it's really rich in fats with the MCT oil and with the er,
the grass fed butter when all that together is,
is blended in with the coffee.
You have to think about it.
That shit takes a long time to digest.
So as is digesting,
it's slowly releasing caffeine,
you know,
so it's all mixed in together.
It's a slow roll instead of just the coffee by itself.
At least this is the theory behind it.
Whatever it is,
it does have an effect.
They're feeding beef.
They're feeding cows.
Uh,
the same Omega threes that are in Salmon,
so now meet will have the exact same effect that salmon has on you.
Wow.
Yeah.
My wife just told me it's like coming out in like two weeks.
That's not good for fish because they're already on shaky ground for pork farm
raised salmon,
fucking looking fucking lizards have the sea creeps.
All creeps.
You know,
of the things I realized when I started fishing,
I love,
I used to love fishing,
but when I would go fishing for Bass and they would sell bass lures,
and I was like,
well,
what does that,
they're supposed to be like a bass fingerling like right out of the mother's
womb.
So because,
uh,
and you know,
they have eggs and I'll have a womb,
you know,
they just ship the acts and the dude comes on it and then they leave the little
fuckers on their own.
But the male basketball oftentimes eat them.
Oh,
wouldn't it be great if women did that if like they did to eight,
somebody who's baggies?
No,
they leave their eggs in the side of a bar and then in order to have it,
maybe I have to go,
come on it.
No,
that's terrible.
But then you could fuck them all you want and you don't have to worry about
getting pregnant.
The only time that works,
the only reason why they do that is when where you live is so bad.
Like it makes Detroit look like the,
the cushiest fucking spot on earth say you,
you fuck,
oh dare you.
If you,
I mean fish,
it's life is so fucked up.
They can't even just chill.
They got to go hit the baby
when the baby's crack out of the eggs.
Oftentimes the hungry bass were like,
fuck it.
I'll just eat one of these.
And they'll just,
they'll eat their own kits.
They're conti little animals.
And as soon as cows can do the same thing,
that fish,
the fish are fucked.
Oh,
can you imagine if you drive a vase or a cow eating a calf?
Whoa.
You'd stop.
Should they do it?
I'm sure the placenta.
The horse.
Yeah,
I know,
but I mean a lot of animals eat their own placenta.
A lot of animals,
a lot of women's posts supposedly do that.
It's supposed to be healthy for you.
It actually people like cook it out of humans.
They have um,
they've taken it.
We were actually going to do that on a fear factor,
but that was one of the things they rejected.
They said no to placenta.
Yes,
yes.
To come and urine.
Way to go.
And Vc,
wait wasn't NBC,
I mean it was individuals that work there.
I'm just saying nothing makes sense.
Bitches on a.com.
Oh and yeah.
Chimpanzee Kettle vow for,
yeah,
get some primal bells.
We hit,
we were in the middle of commercial and we had a talk about coffee.
Are you going to do desk squad kettlebells where it's our likenesses.
We thought about doing a Joey d as a hundred pound would be,
oh,
sleeving sourced it.
We haven't sourced it,
but it would be a real issue.
We'd have to go and take his head and we'd have to like put,
put his head in a mold and Skype being,
but it's on your face.
It's a bigger deal.
I think it's a set.
You get a five pound kettle bell.
That's Brian.
Joelle can get this fucking thing off my head right now.
Pound Kettle Bell,
the donkey walking out with my fucking head.
You Momo
on a.com.
Use the code name rogue and save yourself some money for Christ.
You see her?
We're fixing.
Get busy.
We're fixing a party.
You've fucks
Joe Rogan experience Joe Rogan podcast by night.
Powerful Bert Kreischer the traveling.
This man.
I know the face of the travel channel itself.
Every time I go to the travel channel,
I see your fucking face Bert Kreischer right in the camera.
Thank God I fucking lost weight before this season.
So pig is fucking,
I look at pictures of me.
There was a guy that had a picture of me from,
had Philly,
I guess a year ago.
Yeah.
I was huge man.
To be going off to 15 we hit in the sauce,
hitting the sauce,
hard blues.
It was the booze and eat whatever the fuck you want at the end of the night.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
no better way to throw a fucking monkey wrench in your metabolism.
Right.
Dude,
it's funny.
It's funny you get you.
You get used to feeling sick so much.
Yeah.
You just get used to that sick feeling.
Well,
if you're hung over all the time,
that becomes your reality.
Yeah.
A lot of people you know that you see on TV.
What the fuck are you doing?
A lot of people that you see on TV that,
uh,
what are you doing,
Bryan?
I'm just fixing a camera.
Okay.
Oh,
okay.
This is a lot of people like,
like Bordain.
You can always tell board dames hung over.
He looks at him.
I saw his new show on CNN.
He looks for some for the first time.
He looks like it looks like the roads taken the tear on him.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's been taking
in Toronto for a year.
God,
man.
Yeah.
That's a hard,
he's the canary in the mine for guys like me.
It's a hard life and a,
if you want to do it Busan,
it's even harder.
Yeah.
Now you want to travel the time flying planes and hit the sauce whenever
possible,
but you know,
health be damned.
That's the fun way.
Do it.
What do you want to hear?
What do you want to go out like,
uh,
like,
like who's the fucking preacher?
Joel Asprey.
Joel,
Joel s.
What's that guy's name?
Joel Osteen.
Joel host or you never watch those like those Sunday preachers that are,
that,
that they preached in Atlanta to those mega churches.
Joel Olsteen.
Oh,
one of those guys.
O'Steen who looks great.
Probably 50 years old.
Or do you want to go out like Anthony Bourdain where at your funeral?
Everyone's like in kind of lived a fucking life.
He's a fucking great writer.
Amazing talent.
He knows.
He makes TV fucking good.
It's so hard to make good TV.
I don't,
I,
I will say candidly,
I don't do it,
but like I make mediocre TV.
I make TV that you don't teach a channel four but he made good TV
dude and the dude goes hard.
Okay.
He showed up and uh,
we,
we passed the joint when,
when he did the podcast and there's,
there's a few guys that didn't,
didn't make it that went down that journey.
There's a few in the history of the podcast that tried to get high with us and
then just the whole podcast went into a tank.
It just spiraled out of control.
Stan hope I heard that one.
Oh that was my shirts.
It was a combination mushrooms and we got them high.
Yeah.
Cause I remember I was,
I was on a treadmill that day and I could hear him breathing in the mic and I
was like,
I was laughing hysterically
standing up so crazy.
Yeah.
He doesn't like the weed but,
but Bordain Bordain went deep,
really fucking hung in there.
Every God damn stroke.
I was amazed.
And then when we sat down,
clearly do was barbecued.
He Wa he wanted more a,
I feel like to this day,
like it wasn't like the best host.
And knowing when a guy wants a beer,
you know,
he's such a,
he's so polite.
He wouldn't say,
okay,
you know the one of these,
like Brian had to go,
I think he just Klinkt is beers together.
They're like,
he's looking at an empty bay.
It's hard to host.
He shows up drunk,
like if you'd been drinking.
Anytime I take take a drink,
I always feel like I'm slurring my words overwhelming.
I can't even do like I can do your podcast drunk,
but I can't do mine drunk because you can totally tell.
Well,
I'm the same way.
Yours drunk too.
Like you have to pay attention.
It's your podcast.
You ultimately have to afford.
It was guided in,
you know,
we'll set it loose and then guide at home and then park it and wrap it up at
night where you have to think about that when it's yours.
But if it's not yours,
you're free to just be,
oh yeah.
Yeah.
So even if you're hammered,
you're like,
who cares?
I'm bringing in my trainer this week and bringing him in.
I'm bringing my trainer into the room.
He's gay.
I'm going to talk to them about being gay and then he's going to make me run for
30 minutes.
I need a beer.
Can I get up here?
We might need to,
what's going on?
Gay dudes are to open up his name.
Christopher Walker.
He's gonna be like,
Oh man,
the next day.
And he's like,
listen man,
I'm thinking about adopting a stage name
podcast.
I don't want this to affect.
He's getting,
I want hundreds of thousands of random strangers also knowing that I'm gay.
I'm not scared about,
you know,
he's a,
he's really cool.
He's from England,
he's kind of a stud and uh,
he is definitely a stud.
Does that for me or how's this work?
Is Alcoholic son.
All right.
So,
um,
and so he's going to get me on my treadmill and he's going to run me through one
of his 30 minute runs,
like the speeds and everything,
and then I can then see if they can keep up with me.
Oh,
okay.
That's kind of fun.
Yeah.
You know what I did?
I had a chiropractor come in and do a podcast where the chiropractor,
while he adjusted me,
and a lot of people were like,
you know,
like,
uh,
like it was different and it was a cool to do something different.
And I was like,
yeah.
And so I was like,
I'm always gonna try to throw something interesting in there.
I love sitting and talking with dudes,
but sometimes it's like,
you know,
it's like I'm not that great of an interviewer.
I like talking over people.
That's a common one that takes a while to figure out how to manage and it's
like,
it's hard because you,
you got to,
it's hard to both listen and think about what you're going to say as well.
You know?
That's,
that's the issue with people talking over people is they just can't hold onto
it.
So they got to get it out right away.
You know?
Like,
especially if you're,
if you're just riffing,
like sometimes when you're riffing,
like the idea comes and you don't mean to cut somebody off,
but you do like it takes a while to figure out how to not do that because it
really is a matter of managing those two very specific and very different
things.
Listening and talking and then combining them together in the third thing,
which is a real conversation like did to,
the grossest thing is talking to someone when you know they're not really having
a conversation with you.
Like maybe they have like a preplanned talking points and they might get them
out and then stop and then get them out again and then stop and then you realize
like,
okay,
you're not even dancing with me here.
Yeah,
you,
you got to,
I mean it's one thing to have a thought in your head.
It's another thing to have a script like,
and what you're doing here,
it's like a script.
This isn't like a thought in your head like,
well,
Hey,
this is my point of view.
Thank you as a person.
Let's have a communicate.
You know,
let's,
let's talk.
But sometimes when you're talking to them you realize like this isn't a real
conversation.
This is like an act.
I remember when I first did I apply that to stand up sometimes I remember I was
doing a audition,
not on an addition.
Meet Patrice enrich false.
We're auditioning to see if we could go to Scotland together.
This is when I was young and I had like,
I had to do 15 minutes and that was a lot for me and I had him all the jokes on
the list and I had less.
Next thing I was like going over it,
going over it.
And Patrice is like,
I was at this and I said,
Danny goes,
let me see it.
And so I gave it to him and he ripped it off.
I go,
why don't you do that man,
I'm fucked now.
And he goes,
just talk.
No one wants to hear you.
Practice jokes on stage.
So I had to grow up and just fucking just go,
all right,
I'll just do talk for 15 minutes about whatever.
And it was so much fucking better than had I run down a set list.
But,
and so then I,
nowadays it's like every set I've ever done now is just fucking
speaking and hoping I get from one place to another.
I would not have been happy if someone tore up my set list.
I gotta Tell Ya,
Oh,
that's bullshit.
He's also six,
seven and 350
both.
I don't think you see,
I don't think there's anything wrong with writing things out,
but I think you'll also,
when you go on stage,
that's when you gotta be free.
It'd be free of it.
But the more you rehearse it or practice it over and over in your mind.
I've been like real adamant about that over the last few years.
I think it's made a big difference over the last year that I,
I write down like almost all my bits over and over and over again when I'm
working on like a new set,
like a new sound like I'm working on right now,
completing a new hour,
which is pretty done.
Um,
I write out each bit over and over and over again.
So my my notebook literally I would look like a mad person.
Same thing over and over and over again.
You know,
it's all ridiculous subjects as it is,
but it's the same things.
It's like all work and no play makes jack a dull boy,
you know?
Yeah.
Well you said you used to do something that I never understood until I,
until I wrote my book wasn't that it was like you would say you would actually
write,
you would turn to get out of that sleep thing on your computer so you would call
right room,
right room and you'd write and you'd write and you'd like it help you.
It really helps you work out.
You jokes.
In my head I was like,
I was like,
that sounds good for him,
but that'll never work for me because I write on stage so I'm better on stage.
But then I had to write like flying dildos,
which is not making it into the book.
I wrote,
wrote it out as a story and I was like,
fuck man,
you've really,
when you are forced to sit and write things down and write it out long form,
you come up with so many more tags.
So it's such a better story.
I wrote the machine story and just for the book and it was like,
I,
I'm telling you what to say this,
this for the first time this week.
And I will say that is a good fucking story on stage now.
Like I,
and I've been doing it for a while,
but it's like just writing it,
you really,
it makes you think of everything.
You're like,
fuck,
I need to fill up a room and used to be 16 pages.
Like,
but so now I'm,
now I'm at this place where I want to write everything I fucking have.
It's um,
it,
it applies with almost everything.
Attention and focus.
You get better at things and you don't get better by sort of ignoring even
things that you already know.
Being lazy to go over it.
Yeah.
There's a lot of theirs theirs look like stand up itself.
Like there's all sorts of times where you're going to come up with something
that just didn't exist just out of a conversation and it's great and it's
awesome.
And then you bring it on stage and Holy Shit,
it's my new great bit.
I said this really funny thing,
we're hanging out the other day and it became a great bit.
But that doesn't mean that you can't also get shit by sitting down and doing
that boring work.
Yeah,
like the boring work,
whatever it is.
There's an awesome book on this,
I mentioned a million times,
but if you haven't heard it,
it's called the war of art by a guy named Steven Pressfield talked about silver
book.
It's amazing book.
Fucking love that book.
And what it's about is about overcoming resistance in that sometimes,
and it's not just about writing man,
it can be about losing weight.
It could be about not,
you know,
like getting out of your house and,
and fucking,
uh,
not being a Weirdo.
Like you can get stagnant,
you can get stuck,
you can get trapped in a pattern.
And it's also easy to get trapped in a pattern where you sabotage yourself.
You know,
and that that happens with a lot of people.
A lot of what you do every day,
you know that you've reached you di you hadn't done is you sabotaging yourself.
And it's an usually like in a response to pressure or response to,
you know,
uh,
overwhelming,
obligations or things along those lines.
You know,
people look for distractions to take themselves away from the pressure of life,
but instead he,
you know,
he sort of,
uh,
emphasizes how satisfying it is to embrace it and to be a professional and just
sit down and do the work.
Just do it.
And this is what you do.
This is how you,
is your ethic,
hard to do that.
It's hard to do,
but it's super satisfying to do.
You probably know this,
you probably haven't been dealing this with us for a long time,
but I heard Amy Schumer on Bobby Kelly's podcast talk about what,
how difficult being a hundred percent busy.
It's like when you have like a TV show and you're doing the road and you're
doing a tour and you're doing everything and I was like,
wow,
I really connect with that because I had always been the comic and I think the
majority of our friends are,
I have dealt with this too,
Ari,
Joey,
a Dunkin,
every dude is that do that fucks around all day and then at night you got like
15 to do 15 minutes or 20 minutes and then you've done the work for the day.
Maybe you have a day job,
maybe you audition,
but as far as like working from eight in the morning until fucking 11 number
every night.
Overwhelming.
Yeah,
like having a TV job.
You mean for what?
Amy's still in is way harder than most because she's trying to do a sketch show.
The sketch shows.
We did that with the man show.
Those.
Those are not easy to do by any stretch of the imagination.
There's a lot of work and there's a lot of politicking that goes on.
That shit can be really stressful because everybody doesn't agree.
You know,
this guy is going to have one vision,
he's going to have another vision and you get together and that this fucking
producer doesn't agree with the network.
Who thinks that you go this way and,
and then you got to go on stage that night,
man,
you're gonna,
you're gonna have nothing left.
She came,
she came to my Portland show,
my late Portland Shell showed up and you could see it in her eyes like it's time
to fucking party.
And she even said,
oh,
I know Amy.
I can say what or anything like that.
She goes,
hey,
you have acute future feature.
And I'm like,
what?
She's like,
I'm looking to have somebody
he didn't.
She didn't because I did not,
well,
doesn't she have a boyfriend?
No.
That's also a famous guy.
Nope,
they don't do that anymore.
Eating anymore.
Oh yeah.
But aren't they always on it?
I think,
you know,
I think they're just regular adults.
Just regular adults.
She didn't cheat anyone,
so it doesn't really matter.
And she might've been saying it,
the joke,
you know,
look,
you're trying to get them on and talking about getting everybody in trouble
here.
Yeah.
Talk about that shit on the podcast.
Amy was a fun,
we got,
we drank in my hotel room until four in the morning.
She's a real comic.
She really is.
Yeah.
She's
the legit,
you know,
and whether or not that TV show works out for her.
She's a,
she's a real comic.
It's a good show.
I bet it is.
She's funny as shit man.
But you know,
whatever she does,
it should be awesome.
Yeah.
She's,
she's legit.
You know,
if you're funny,
you're funny.
She reminds me of my oldest daughter.
Really?
They,
they,
they have a,
she has a blue jumper,
like a baby blue jumper that she,
Amy,
when we used to,
we worked on a show together that she wore one time and I went,
I thought,
I haven't seen anyone in a jumper like shorts and like a jumper.
And one day Georgia has the exact same jumper on and I was like,
Holy Shit.
And she looked fucking just,
I gave me,
I called Amy and took a picture of Georgia,
sent it to her.
But yeah,
she reminds me a lot of Amy.
Yeah.
There's a fraternity of comedians.
Right.
It's nice.
I ran into him at the airport.
Girls in there.
Yeah.
We ran into each other at the airport.
Standard Point says that.
So it was fun running into a community in the airport.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Him,
her,
her feature and her road manager at a bar at like seven in the morning in
Portland.
Like I,
we had partied two nights before,
but then we all were on the same flight,
random at in New York and we were getting down at the bar.
I just ran into Marin.
Shut up.
Yeah.
We were both in Indianapolis at the same time and we're on the same flight and
he was right behind me.
That's hilarious.
Fucking,
it's great.
Yeah,
it's cool.
And I wouldn't change seats to sit next to one on a plane now,
but it's fun running into might if it was someone cool,
you know,
but then I shouldn't have said that.
You.
There are certain comedians that I'm not really into hanging out with and if
they cornered me,
it would kind of suck.
You know,
let's just go down the list.
That's a gospel.
Uh,
yeah.
I know what you're saying.
I'd never,
anytime I'm about,
look,
I'm,
I'm not sitting next to you and God didn't mean for us to sit next to each
other.
I don't want to sit next to you.
You know what is a,
a little element in society that we too quickly accepted what the people that
have a stand that they set up in front of the exit door at the fucking grocery
store.
Oh,
cons,
gay and lesbians,
whatever it is,
mine the other day.
And they were like,
take a second for gambling.
Yes,
yes.
The Guy,
the guy.
Do you have one minute for gay rights
finger in my face?
And I went,
no,
I don't like him.
And he was like,
excuse me.
I go,
I'm kidding.
I don't have time,
man.
And he was like,
wait,
hold on Gip.
And now you're like,
commit a hate crime by just passing them by.
Yeah.
It's guilt.
It's like the guilt stop after you walking out with your organic vegetables.
Take two seconds to make sure we're porn stairs.
Wear condoms.
I'm with my kids.
I'm like,
I go,
no thanks.
Did they really say that?
I swear to God outside the target,
the target porn stars wear condoms.
Daddy,
what's a condom?
I'm with my daughters and my wife and,
but I sold myself out quick and was like,
ah,
no way am I want to say excuse me.
And I was like,
who wasn't where common.
It was like,
I don't,
I want them not to have you.
I go,
have you ever seen a point where they're wearing condoms?
And she's like,
no,
I've never seen a porn.
I go,
it's fucking bomb has never seen it.
Porn.
My wife has never seen a porn.
Wow.
She's potatoes,
potatoes and she doesn't,
she doesn't squirt easy with that house.
Your wife,
both of
what?
A No consensus on what that squirting stuff is.
Dana d Imani,
apparently she's changed her position,
but she told me it was pissed.
She saw me.
This girl's a p and each other and now apparently she does not.
There's not,
there's not a gland inside a vagina that produces a liter of fluid too,
so it explodes at the end and not real.
No,
no,
no.
It's,
it's 100% real.
It's not even like a fucking conspiracy to red band over here.
100% it's 100% proven that it's not pissed.
Look,
I've been,
I've had squirt in my mouth millions of times.
I haven't definitely not your mouth.
It's definitely not pee.
It's a 100% okay,
here we go.
I did
and I got to the myth.
Here's the myths about squirting.
Okay.
Ready?
Myth number one that it's p wow.
Many experts believe that what comes out of a woman,
she's a Jackie waiting his urine,
but women who squirt will tell you otherwise.
Some have given it the smell,
even taste test and insist.
It's not.
P researchers determined that the fluid admitted during orgasm showed all the
characteristics of prostate plasma.
What is that?
Don't Bam.
When you don't even know what that is.
Brian.
He's like,
yeah,
told you the pilot was on
and not urine and concluded.
This might be proof that our para youth,
real hmm.
Skins gland,
where the fluid comes from,
function as female prostate glands.
Wow.
So apparently the theory is that in,
in some women,
this one gland can also,
it functions almost as like in a jacket.
I'll tell you,
I'm willing to accept that.
Not I'm willing to accept that possibly there is a minority of women just like
Puffy Nipples,
like puppy nipples or something that not everyone has.
But then you see them and you know what I mean?
I'm pretty sure I could make any girl squirt a hundred percent Brian throw up.
Yeah,
for sure.
Not that kind of squares.
I be like,
listen,
if this is what it takes to get them out of the bed,
I'll piss in it.
But this is what it says.
This mean,
this website is saying that every woman is capable of doing it.
They just have to learn.
Okay.
So it says there are lots of experts and female sex.
They only tell you what website this is called,
the Frisky,
the frisky.
Dot Com and it's six myths about squirting.
If you want to look forward to yourself,
if you're like,
hmm,
I'd like to know more about
squirting Joe.
There's actually a video,
it's also online that will teach you how to actually make a girl squirt.
Cause there's two like two main ways to make a girl squirt and obviously the one
is you know
her g spot and if you just hit her g spot,
like if you're licking the pussy and you have a finger on the g spot the whole
time and your effort,
you can make her squirt that way.
Or if you just know the right positions to fuck her at your Dick and hit that g
spot and it's really easy to do and you could just watch this video and you can
make real squirts and that it's really easy to do.
Yeah.
But I saw a girl squirt when she was getting fucked up or,
but how's that work?
Because that's a different kind of,
uh,
orgasms.
Christ.
That's not the same.
That's not g spot where it goes.
That's actually that orgasm that she had is actually a deeper,
harder to get orgasms.
So you didn't really see that.
But a lot of them aren't yet.
But a lot of porn actually fakes a squirting in Port Elizabeth.
This is a hardcore,
I know a lot about squirting man.
I like [inaudible].
I know a lot about squirting dude.
I have waterproof sheets now because it will ruin your warranty on your mattress
if it starts getting girls farting.
That's one position.
Um,
so this is another one.
It's also saying that it's not,
that's a myth that it's caused by the stimulation of the g spot.
Okay.
Every woman is not capable of doing it.
I'm sorry when I said that,
that's actually a myth.
So it's one of the cases,
one of the things that they're saying,
it's a myth.
Every woman's capable then never woman's not capable.
This is saying in the five myths,
one of them is,
is not p two is that every woman is capable of doing it.
They just have to learn.
She's saying no or he or whoever wrote this,
ask Jeeves has a different opinion.
It's Amy.
A woman they name.
Oh No,
I made her squirt
Ami.
So I guess the dude,
sorry.
Ami when named John.
Amy,
Bro.
I'm sorry.
Um,
regardless everything you like porn porn.
I've disconnected the tad bit from porn because I,
I still watch it,
but it just seems like a lot of the shit,
the way you've seen a porn just isn't stuff that happens to this website.
Just lost me.
You just said exactly what I was reading,
which is hilarious.
Are you sure?
Yes,
exactly why you were saying this.
It's at number six as far as the mess of porn,
that what you see in porn is real.
The porn is unrealistic sexual expectations and imposes upon us.
We see a large amount of fluid squirting out of a woman's vagina in porn.
Keep in mind this could be faked by putting water in her vagina before filming
or having a woman p on camera.
One Who can have Jackie late will tell you that it's easiest when you're relaxed
and having cameras on you is not the most relaxing when experience pleasure.
I've talked about my free cams before it.
That's the biggest thing right now the other girls are doing is they have these
dildos that actually have water in it pushes the water in you and then they
explode and so every girl's squirting,
right?
Yeah.
That's what it looks like.
So may,
so there you go.
While you were saying that while you were saying that I was reading it
serendipity.
It's crazy man.
It's like you and I are like connected to Bernie journey.
I feel like we already are chemo savvy.
It's like the new ad for the lone ranger with Johnny Depp.
That's what I feel like,
dude,
Johnny Depp is,
this is,
this is how this,
this is how my conversations work.
Okay.
Johnny Depp is the prototype for the death squad compound.
Johnny Depp is,
Johnny Depp owns a whole street in Los Angeles and the Hollywood hills and he's
got the whole fucking street.
I'm not going to take anything where he is where or anything like that,
but he owns every house.
He just bought them all except for like one so that no one can move near island
can move in and he's,
and it's just as it just fucking loads it out.
It's all his boys.
He was like,
lots of smart move.
Fuck yes,
but you know how much real estate is you gotta have ball or type money sign?
You got to have more money than me.
No,
I'm not asking you to buy it.
I'm saying what we need to do is we need to start a fucking organization and by
a street did not want to be down the street from this motherfucker.
I'm all about that squad car.
One of the gals comes home in the middle of the night and finds this some
fuckery afoot screen squirting.
It's five in the morning and he,
he's stuttering,
arguing and stuff.
I want to be around a bunch of guys.
I'm like my privacy,
you know,
if I want to fucking take somebody home,
I don't want everyone in the fucking know about it.
You know how everybody know about it?
You're like desperate housewives,
but with a bunch of guys.
Oh No,
I want to own a Johnny Depp my life.
I just want to
make over there
Johnny privacy.
All of a sudden you fucked.
Somebody tells everybody,
hey guys,
I make every girl squirt.
I need my privacy guy
making girls squirt.
It's pretty easy to do.
And you can learn how to teach yourself.
I'm saying.
Yeah,
that's exactly what I'll do is after sex I have to get up and changes dated a
few girls with broken vagina sign.
Congratulations.
It just pissing all over.
He's silly.
Fuck.
Um,
so,
okay.
How about let's Google squirting is not real.
How
I wrote a Google squirting is fake.
But uh,
how can you fucking research a subject while you're on,
I'm telling you right now,
how could you drank it,
Joe Merrill's.
Okay.
Gallons.
You'd be dead.
Can you see possibly how we,
your,
your opinion might be suspect.
Brian,
I am telling you this is something that some women is definitely real.
I think here's another website.
Squirting who's for real and who's faking it.
Oh No,
this is websites that are debating whether or not women are fake and who's
faking it.
And how to know proof squirting is fake.
This is silly.
Well,
you know what?
I don't think it's fake.
I think too many people say do it in too many girls do do it.
I think that is a lot of people that do fake it.
But apparently one of the myths is that every woman can do it and [inaudible]
not every woman can do it apparently.
And it depends upon that one gland.
Some women,
they have that,
that gland access.
It's like gagging like,
like,
like a lot of women gag,
like some women gag during sex,
but now think a lot of what goes
on in porn is a lot of over the top gagging like when Morris,
and so it's what it is,
is it works one time.
It's just like fucking comedy.
It worked.
One time.
Savannah Samson got deep throat by Rocco's to Friday's and cried,
you know,
too much.
Someone Yoshi told me,
if you want to see where you want to see,
like what he was inspired,
what inspires him?
He's like,
watch it.
He goes,
it's tough.
It's tough to watch.
Why is it tough to watch?
Uh,
she is not a porn star at the time.
She's married and she is her.
She asked for her anniversary for her husband to go to France and fuck rockets
or Fridays or Italy,
maybe,
maybe France,
no one,
nine barrels.
So they go to,
um,
she flies over.
It turned another girl,
but the other girl was clearly like,
um,
trail friendly with Rocco's Freddy.
She's written it before.
She knows what to expect in the curves.
Savannah's Sampson does not.
I am,
I'm telling you right now is one of the most aggressive pieces of porn I've ever
witnessed it is it she's crying within like the first five minutes and it's a 45
minute fuck.
It's like,
like she is,
is that her?
Huh?
What is that?
It's you,
you fuck.
Oh No.
What did you say?
Whoa.
No,
there Brian's pulling something up.
he didn't get anything.
So,
uh,
is it,
I feel like now I feel like we're getting,
getting pranked.
So I'm so,
no,
but within the first five minutes,
she is like,
like she can't breathe and she sits in the thing and it is the realist fucking
reaction.
He goes,
did you like that?
Did you like that?
Did you like be all you can be on this?
Maybe you can be on this baby if you did not like you can tell me.
And she's wiping tears away from where I was sick.
I didn't really like that.
And he goes,
oh,
then we just need to find another position.
Laser on her back and starts throwing fucking her.
And she's like,
you can just see her body going.
And then this is an acting.
It's Yoshi man.
Yoshi is a,
at the,
it is,
this is how Savannah Sampson got her start.
Is that the anal sex scene is so fucking real that you literally,
did she ever tell him to stop?
Uh,
no,
because this was her anniversary gift.
She wanted this.
Okay.
So she enjoyed it.
Uh,
that's debatable.
She did come back the next night and do it again,
but I don't know if she enjoyed it.
The fuck are you even saying?
I don't know if she,
if you got to watch it and go crazy and that's why she did it twice.
I met her,
she's pretty,
uh,
pretty out there,
but,
but she became a porn store right after this because it was such a popular video
that she,
like all of a sudden she was married,
she was married,
she was a stripper scores and she said her husband for my anniversary,
I want to go over and fuck Rocco's Freddy's wow.
And she did.
And the husband said,
I'm cool with that.
Yeah.
Husband's like,
I'm cool.
I think there's still married.
I want to say they're still married.
I am guessing defense jokes.
But yeah.
Have you watched the video?
I just googled it and it's like,
it's,
it's the first bit of Gonzo porn now.
Gonzo porn is like,
I'm talking like I'm an expert.
Important.
I just,
I've watched you and him together get together and start your own fucking school
and how to teach people about what really goes on in bedrooms.
But yeah,
I that now I see now I now I watched that.
I was telling Brian it's hard to watch follow some girls on vine because you've
seen them in porn and then you see them on vine as a,
as like a regular person.
Yeah.
What's that girl's name again?
Like it then it's like the whole time I'm like,
it's almost like seeing a,
it's like seeing someone undercover cause it's like this girl that you've seen
just too fucking crazy shit that she's at the Kentucky Derby just hanging out
with regular people and they're all hanging out with her.
And pardon me,
it was like,
oh my God.
Like it really is kind of voyeuristic going like sexism.
It's a weird thing.
It's like everybody wants to do it but nobody wants you to see him do it.
We have like weird things like that.
Especially like women,
like a woman who's willing to let the whole world here.
Fuck.
That's like,
that's a really gangster move for girl.
I,
it's,
it's amazing how many guys would do it if you didn't show their face.
Every guy.
Yeah,
maybe.
But I mean,
it's just the,
it's the whole thing is weird.
It's weird that people want to see you.
It's weird that you want to see them.
It's weird that,
you know,
we hide our nakedness from each other.
I mean,
just close themselves are so odd.
The,
the body is like literally accepting a constant symbiotic relationship to its
own creations.
A constant relationship with clothing,
with shoes,
with pants,
with your,
you're constantly draped in close.
Even when you're on the,
in a beach,
you,
your clothes are represented there.
Skimpy little thing that just covers the minimal areas.
But when you know,
you get naked and he gets sexual,
it's like that's the only time when you're completely,
you know,
rid of these clothes and that's just temporary.
And do that for a little bit and get your clothes back on.
Yeah.
It's like we have this weird relationship with clothes,
man.
It's like we've just accepted that these fucking things that we make are a part
of our everyday life with no question whatsoever.
And that to have that,
that not be the case is bad.
And then when,
and then like my daughter's going through tactile issues with clothing.
Like she doesn't like wearing,
she doesn't like wearing like,
uh,
she asked for a knee high socks,
shit.
Watch to wear cowboy boots.
Like some clothes feel comfortable.
I have the same problem.
I don't wear underwear because it's
never,
I've never,
I've,
I haven't wore underwear in a long time because it drives me fucking cotton.
A zipper.
So you never have accidents and being somebody that drinks a lot of course.
Well first of all,
drinking lot.
It doesn't mean shit.
Your pants a lot by a lot.
Yeah.
Well I mean once a month and so,
no,
I've definitely shit my pants,
but I've,
don't worry,
I'm fine there.
Brody 30 says he at least sits itself like once every two weeks.
There's one he probably does.
I just,
cause he had the board.
No,
but I'm still to go back to your point is that once someone does have issues
with closing,
they're broken and you've got,
you go,
oh,
we gotta fix that.
And you're like,
well,
it's weird.
Why is what you're saying is it's not natural to us.
Like you look at a three piece suit,
how fucking ridiculous to say I was,
I went to see the great Gatsby last night.
It suck.
No,
it did not suck man.
People keep saying that it sucked because they made some
really odd choices and one of the really odd choices,
where did they use a lot of modern music like Jay z music and there's rap music
in there,
but it's a period piece about the 1920s.
Like why would you have,
why would you have Jay z plan and why would you have a hip hop?
Why would you have like popular music like a,
what's that girl's name?
Alana Ray,
I think she's saying it sounds like her.
And it was,
it's too obviously,
uh,
modern and I thought it was really fascinating that they did it that way.
I don't necessarily know if it was the best way to do it,
but it gave an unmistakable energy that worked,
you know,
it was really good.
So like people complaining that they were using this rap and it just,
I see what you're saying,
but if you just said,
can accept it as a work of art,
it's like a visual masterpiece.
I saw it in three D it's an amazing movie.
The way they shot it.
It's one of the most beautiful movies I've ever seen in my life.
Did you bring your own glass?
Ratable?
No,
no,
no.
You get them there,
but,
but they're not real.
They're,
they're not the paper ones.
Right.
They're plastic.
You recycle.
Yeah.
I've never been,
I've never been to it.
Three d movies bother me.
Oh,
the new Three d man is amazing.
I've never yet they have now God damn this.
Um,
if you,
if you go to see,
uh,
the great Gatsby need,
don't see the three d you're going to miss on half the movie because it's just
the effect that it created.
I mean,
it's visually,
it's stunning.
It really is like a work of art.
Like you bet it is beautiful.
It's so beautiful.
It's just the way it's shot is beautiful.
The way it's edited as beautiful.
It's an amazing movie,
man.
I mean I saw the great gay or read the Great Gatsby in high school.
I saw,
I really barely remember the plot and I was sort of picking things up as I went
along.
So going into it with that,
um,
I really enjoyed it but I know people that have read it recently and they didn't
enjoy it as much because they felt like it deviated too much from,
uh,
from the book.
But I can't say that because again,
I'm not going to read it again.
And it was a long ass time ago but it was a really enjoyable movie
was really good.
It's fucking interesting.
It's hard to do those period pieces with music.
There was a,
there was a movie that was made by outkast called Idlewild,
the band outcast.
Yeah.
Pop.
And they did all their own music and it was set in like the 30s,
but it was cool as shit because they did all the music.
Yeah that's bad ass.
Like they should have hired,
I think they should have hired some band to do all the music and just make it
real.
Right,
right.
Cause that Glenn Miller was a bad ass.
Fucking Glenn Miller was the prototype for Badass rock stars.
He was the m and m but in World War II.
You anything Buckland Miller.
Yeah,
he went into the army,
any of that song,
bum,
Bom,
bom and Amanda
like it was bad and he went over and flew fucking planes and then died in world
war one.
I think it was Warren.
Yeah.
Or maybe it was too.
I don't know.
Um,
I might be,
I may not even be Glenn Miller.
Fuck you got a story in my head and I'm like,
oh no idea.
I want to,
that is accurate.
Well,
I,
I see that you would want to have mood music in a movie about a period of the
music from that period.
Like get it girl talk to do it,
but this child and this chance that they took,
I'm telling you,
it worked.
It worked for me at least.
I thought it was an amazing movie.
But I was amazed also when I went on rotten tomatoes when I saw it only got like
43%.
How does that work?
I never understand how wrong the world is.
Overrun with comments.
That's what I say.
I think the current infestation that we have is that an unprecedented high level
and I think clients are much more likely to be mouthy.
They're much more likely to be active then.
Then the people that are honestly reviewing things from a point of view where
you know,
you could relate to them or where you could,
uh,
you know,
you could get something out of the reviews.
It's a lot of people.
You're not getting shit out of the review.
You're getting their shitbag personality.
Like you ever go on Yelp and you see five star,
five star,
one star,
read that one star read and then go to their page and read what a miserable cunt
bag human being that is.
Nine Times out of 10,
it's just someone just spewing,
um,
the,
I,
I gave someone a negative review.
I joined Yelp to give a negative view.
That's arrogant.
How dare you,
how dare they,
what did they do?
I will go in,
what is this business?
It's a restaurant,
a restaurant.
I go in,
I'm excited about the food.
I go in and I get attitude,
like I want to sit by myself.
It's,
it's 11.
There's no one in there,
right?
Like 1130,
no one's in there.
And I go,
yeah,
okay.
She can take a one for one.
And she,
the girl,
the front goes,
well,
did you just want to sit at the bar?
And I'm like,
not know or I wouldn't have asked for a table for one,
but I'm like,
well yeah,
I'll go to the bar.
So I go to the parks.
I don't want to be a dick.
I got a beer.
Really cute.
Wait a bartender.
Really Nice guy or girl.
Girl.
Girl,
And so they have this cute
for boys,
you know that,
right?
No,
you're growled damn man.
With a heavy manly beer.
Don't call it girl.
Cute
little hottie.
So she,
uh,
she,
I said,
how does this,
it was a Turkey,
um,
Turkey hot Turkey barbecued southern style mustard barbecue sauce on it.
I love mustard barbecue sauce.
I fucking love,
like when you get the three,
the two of choice,
four hours go for monster.
Okay.
So I go,
this'll be fucking great.
So it comes out and it looked good.
The Turkey's not [inaudible].
It looks like it might've been coming in a package,
but it's hot.
And then I go and there's not that much to the sauce.
So I go,
can I get more sauce?
And they go,
yeah.
So I put the sauce on.
It's just mustered.
They've indoctrinated at all.
So I go,
Oh,
this is just mustering.
She goes,
and the girl says,
yeah,
it looked kind of fucking odd when it came out.
That doesn't look like what it should look like.
And I go,
oh,
and she goes,
I,
I'd like to take it off your bill,
but the GM is in here.
I go,
well,
let me talk to the cook the chef,
and I'll tell him that it isn't what it was.
Stupid fucking cunt came out,
arms like this on the bar.
Yeah.
What?
And I go,
is this the mustard?
And he goes,
yeah,
yeah.
I go,
how do you guys make your mustard barbecue sauce?
And he goes,
vinegar,
honey.
Like mustard.
Yeah,
like real dicky.
And I go,
well,
just,
just wasn't,
it wasn't what I thought it was going to be.
He goes,
maybe we should just change the name on the menu and then,
Huh?
And I was like a gas and then he was like,
yeah,
well sorry.
And walked away.
And I went,
okay,
I'm joining Yelp,
I'm joining the,
but I'm telling you everyone of fuck this place is the place.
Uh,
uh,
I don't want to say it now because
everyone knows it.
Yup.
And your name's Bert Kreischer on Yelp.
Dick,
what are you working on?
Just getting to know.
Let me tell you what,
let me tell you what happened.
Let me tell you what happened afterwards.
This is obviously,
this is also the fucking shitty thing about Yelp.
Okay.
So I posted,
posted on Yelp.
Yelp goes automatically to your Twitter and it,
and it gets tweeted and then all of a sudden these people see it.
Now I have 84,000 followers on Twitter.
So everyone's like,
start saying like,
what happened?
What was it?
And these people have 350 and they start seeing it and they're like,
oh shit.
So then they start coming at me like,
hey,
like it's the way Yelp works is they find out if you give him a bad review and
then they want you to take it off because that really does affect our business.
So it became a pain in the fucking ass.
And then I felt like a cyber bully for saying I didn't like a meal.
I should have just kept my mouth shut and walked away.
But it was like they were such assholes and they were like,
come back in.
And I was like,
there's no way I'm coming back in.
It was in Baltimore.
It was named,
uh,
you didn't delete frank,
frank and nic's.
You deleted your review.
No I didn't.
I left it up.
Fuck that guy.
Yeah,
I think it's called frank and nic's frank and next.
And where was it?
It was in Baltimore right next to Camden yards.
It was right next to the stadium.
And I,
and I was excited cause everyone was like,
well you should really give it a second chance.
And I was like,
I would,
but I wrote about bad review.
I'm going to know that.
And I know that the chef was chefs a big word for what this dude was.
The Cook was a fucking Dick and I would not put it past him to make sure I did
not enjoy it again.
I'm not gonna let it,
I'm not gonna let a dude,
I don't like that.
I made it vocal.
Make something that I'm going to put my mouth.
That's a very good move.
So I didn't go,
but,
and then I felt bad,
but then everyone was like,
I went and did radio and they were like,
next morning they're like,
what's your problem with frank and nic's?
And I was like,
Oh,
you know what?
They need to hear that too because someone needs to not do that.
Someone needs to,
if you're,
you're going to be a chef and a guy has a question about the food,
not come out and be a fucking cock sucker like that.
And when you do,
there's repercussions.
He had to say,
I mean it's,
it's not like it's money out of his pocket.
He's probably been doing that to people his whole life,
acting douchey because it puts people on their heels and it makes people easier
to deal with in his feeble little mind.
Yeah.
All you had to do was say,
well,
let me get you something else.
Yeah.
I mean like,
you know,
I,
but I,
so I was,
I was welcoming all this negative energy and I just fucking stopped.
I was like,
I'm gonna stop.
And so I'm now at,
and then I'm not going to Yelp and fucking thing unless I like it.
Oh,
y'all.
Things like,
if I don't like it,
I'm not gonna put it up there to warn people.
Well,
there's not,
there's nothing wrong with telling a true good story,
you know?
But what's wrong is the people that you look at their thing and they're not
happy about it.
The world.
Well,
it's,
it's people,
like there was a woman.
So my wife and I are in large bond.
Uh,
she's getting her hair done and I'm just walking around Larchmont to burn
calories.
We go into this restaurant,
this little Mexican place.
I won't say mom and pop
because that's what it looked like.
Then there was like,
like the cousin was working,
the front dad was making tortillas,
moms in the back and this woman comes in and goes,
are you are with the large amount of business says Asian.
It's like 11 o'clock just be my wife and the kids like I dunno man.
And she's like,
well cause I don't frequent places that aren't with the Larchmont business
association because we pay to clean.
Like she came in and this conti attitude,
I was so offended that I was like,
how dare you walk in with all this negative energy and then dump it on people.
And then what happened was she actually was like smiling at the end cause we
welcomed all her negative shit and then she left in like a good mood.
We're all fucking cunty now because she put it on us.
Yeah.
But that's just because she's an unaware Douche.
How could you cause that kind of term loan and leave feeling like you're in a
good mood.
Yeah.
But it's
porn to let people know that that's gross.
They don't even,
a lot of times those people don't even realize how gross they're band.
Yeah.
It's like when you tell this cook and he's obviously going to feel terrible
about this,
that shit's good for him.
He shouldn't be doing that.
You know?
That's his best,
very sensitive relationship that a person who cooks food has to the person that
is eating that food.
And I'm always super nice to cooks,
always super nice to chefs,
but if I'm ran into a guy like that,
I would have the same reaction.
I bet that you did.
And when you have that reaction,
he needs to know that he's facing that reaction because this is a direct result
of his behavior and that should help him evolve as a person.
It was,
there's only one of those in the city that one place has like 350 followers on
Twitter.
And Trust me,
when I say word got back like I call,
sure it's going to give back even worse now.
I'm never fucking going back there.
I'm on now.
I'm fucking the guys,
you know?
Look man,
it's good for him though.
It's like I've,
I've definitely been in situations where I handled hecklers incorrectly and I,
I learned a lesson and I know now know how to deal with it,
you know,
but at the same time,
yeah,
it's um,
it's still a learning curve and when I do fuck up,
I,
you know,
it's like I know it though.
I think comedy is one of those things where it's like dealing with the same
situation.
Yeah.
You're talking about someone heckling you.
Hecklers or hackers are fucking assholes.
Heckler,
you had a question about the food because it was,
it was supposed to be a mustard sauce and it was just muster.
It's just mustard.
It was young discussing that is just having mustard on the Turkey.
I like Turkey with mustard,
but like I need mandates to,
okay.
That's all you,
I understand you just do Turkey and mustard.
I just,
I usually just it
Turkey.
I like hot sauce better than mustard because I know,
well,
mustard is not bad for you.
Um,
not,
not really high caloric.
Um,
but um,
but mayonnaise is,
man is not so great for.
What about Serratia?
That sounds great.
For it.
Fucking,
yeah.
I mean,
if you just want to add some flavor to something like a mayonnaise tastes so
good.
God Damn.
You know what's the best that I've been?
I forgot.
Forgot how good it was.
A fried egg sandwich with mayonnaise and hot sauce.
Fuck.
Oh,
fried egg sandwich with some fucking melted cheddar cheese and mayonnaise and
hot sauce and it's not expensive.
It's an expensive meal.
It's a really reasonable meal.
I'll take that with mustard.
Just mustard and a egg sandwich.
Fuck yeah.
Oh,
that's good too.
Yeah,
the
grey poupon Shit.
Nice with it as well.
I don't mind.
I don't mind like a lettuce and tomato on that egg sandwich too.
I don't mind that either.
A little fiber,
little crunchiness to it and we'll snap fucking hungry by the way.
Squirt per dotcoms life,
Joe.
It's a lot of square for a second.
This whole fucking time I get out,
Jo,
I can't show it up close.
I have to shut this version of you just play.
It doesn't do anything.
Oh Jeez.
Oh No.
You've been doing this whole fucking do something that girls pissing on that
dude.
That's me.
That's what's a fake one at Burt's doing.
That one was actually real.
Yeah,
he came the hardest ever.
Oh my God.
Hey,
will you put my tour dates up on support cause I know a million people are going
to
tell us where you're at.
We'll talk next week.
You're doing cap city kept sitting next week.
Joey Diaz just did it so to Bunce Tommy,
but it's just this past weekend.
I'm there.
Not this weekend,
but next weekend the 20 I didn't even know Joey was there so I didn't even tweet
it for him and he sold out two shows.
That is a powerful fucking feeling.
I will tell you right now,
I'm in there the 20 May 23rd 24th 25th 24th and the 25th of 24th 23rd 24th 25th
of May.
I'm excited to go back to all to cities.
That shit.
I would like to live
Texas,
man.
I would like to live in Austin.
They look problem with Austin is that Austin surrounded by some funky areas.
It's like the Austin itself.
Yeah.
Austin itself is beautiful.
The people are progressive people.
Progressive.
They're interesting.
There's a lot of artists.
There's a lot of musicians.
This is a lot of like fake,
fake fucking Dorks,
fake artistic dorks put.
That's always going to be the case.
There's a lot of real ones too.
There's a lot of really good musicians to come from there.
I love when you see like someone that really is like a fucking true artists,
but it's not something that is like,
look what worked with a glass blower down there and she was fucking amazing.
Hard to make money.
It's very hard to make money class blonde,
but it's her.
It's what she digs and you're like,
that's fucking bad ass.
Yeah,
it is.
You know,
the,
the ability to pursue like whatever the fuck excite to,
to create whatever,
whatever it is.
It's places that support that.
It's places that don't.
Yup.
And Austin has a really good spot for that.
Good comedy.
They're too good community.
Never done stand up there.
It's fucking amazing TV shows down there.
But last time was there.
We sold out a Austin city limits.
That big theater.
There was a fantastic,
is that outdoors?
No,
no,
no.
It's indoor.
It's a beautiful place.
And this is,
the crowd was alive.
Mance fun.
So fun.
I'm excited to go down there.
It's Jamie.
Oh Jamison Cups,
ice and Ginger Ale.
This part of the episode is now going to be called going deep with Bert
Kreischer.
It's called.
It just got real deal.
Squirt Shit.
Just got
real squirting Jamieson ice.
Um,
I think we're good right now.
Yeah,
that's good.
Yeah.
Put it together,
Bert.
MMM.
So where are you going?
You go into Austin and where else?
Then I take a week off for that.
I'm in Demoine,
the Philly and Buffalo.
Ooh,
Moines dude.
I'm fucking,
I go,
I take a week off,
uh,
after Austin and I'm on the road every single weekend until Christmas.
Wow.
It's the first time in my life that I'm making money on the road.
Like where you like,
you get excited,
you remember that turn?
Where do you were like,
you're no longer making like say like breaking even or losing money a lot of
times,
but you're making money and it's not a lot,
but you're just got like,
you get excited and you're like fucking and then,
and I'm writing quicker,
faster,
cleaner than I've ever written.
Like things are getting on stage really quick.
Men,
I'll tell you,
I've,
I've taken some very big strides in finding my voice recently in storytelling.
You forcing me to tell that machine story on stage has made me so much better of
a comic.
Well,
it's just the stories themselves are so good.
It has nothing to do with me telling you to do it.
Alpha brain,
awful,
awful brand.
Are we just going to do shots,
guys?
You guys going to do a shot?
Um,
whatever.
You're the fucking,
you're the frat boy,
frat boy,
bartender.
I had a,
I have,
um,
God dammit,
the guy on my fucking playing yesterday.
How funny is this?
He gets up and look,
I'm,
I'm fairly sensitive and like,
and like words,
sometimes I'll just hear it and I'll go,
oh,
that.
And he goes,
he comes up to first class,
he says [inaudible] the platinum.
And he's like,
he's like,
Hey,
uh,
I'm a total retard.
He goes,
uh,
I was supposed to sub get up for an upgrade,
but no upgrade to have.
So like I'm gonna go run up in up,
I can't believe what,
how retarded.
He's not like retarded like three times.
And I'm just sensitive to that cause I'm like,
man,
like that's a little,
that's like old school.
Like no,
right.
No need,
no need to use it.
None use retard anymore.
Not In that situation.
You can definitely like your kid glues his hand to the fucking desk.
Call him a retard,
but oh,
you don't call your Kinda Retard Jesus Christ.
I'll call my kid one,
but not I it.
But it was like in public.
I was like,
oh my God.
So do you want to,
how great this was,
man.
He goes up to the front to go get his upgrade fucking door playing closes and
they fucking left him there.
Oh really?
Fucking left.
I go,
stepped down.
He stepped out,
door shut and they fucking left him.
And I went,
I wonder if they left his laptop in there too.
I said to him,
you need to get all your carry on off.
The plaintiffs are going to go talk to them.
Do you see that once too?
Or just they've got arrested because a,
the guy left his iPad on the plane and she took it home and he had a track my
iPad thing going on.
I'm not drinking.
Okay.
It havey if you,
instead of calling your kid's retarded,
he caught her kids like niggers.
What did that end racism
wouldn't it?
It would make the word like mean nothing.
That's an old Lenny joke from 1960.
Can you give me some ice because it really,
yeah.
Yes it is.
Yeah.
I had a whole thing.
He had a whole thing about saying it over and over again til uh,
so it lose its meaning,
which is,
yeah.
Which is,
you know,
it's,
there's,
there's some argument to that,
but culturally it is what it is.
You know,
the problem with the words like that is,
yeah.
Logically it's a stupid thing to have one word have so much power.
It's dumb to have like an upper level insult.
It's,
it's almost like it shows too much power in what the human language can produce
as opposed to like what we should allow people to,
uh,
to affect us by.
It has way too much power,
you know,
cause it can,
someone can call you anything else and it doesn't have nearly the same.
Like I'm going to fight you thing as that and that's,
that is in itself really stupid,
but it's real.
So unfortunately it's like you got those two things to deal with.
He got your,
you,
your objective assessment of it,
which is like this is a stupid like why is that word so big?
Why is it such a big deal?
You know,
isn't intent what's important and the,
and niggers even crazier because black people are allowed to use it freely
anytime they want.
They can just toss it back and forth and no one bats an eye but a white person.
Even in using it the way I did it.
Just saying that it is a word not calling anyone in,
not defining it,
just saying this is the name of that word is controversial.
It's hilarious.
It's a really one of the most ridiculous aspects of our culture,
but it is an aspect of our culture.
So it's like in exposing it,
you got to give people the option to recognize how ridiculous it is and then
eventually we'll probably move past it,
but we're stuck in this like swampy adolescent area,
what was developed.
We're still stuck there because there is a,
there's a large group of the population of black people who were alive when that
word meant a really not meant what was used.
Me Too,
man.
No,
no,
no.
I knew it was it.
Now someone's angry.
Yeah,
but what I'm saying is what I'm saying is there's a group of like say 50 to 70
year old black people where that word was very,
now the the,
I'd say the hip hop youth uses it as a term of endearment often.
Right.
But what we're talking about is once you get to a place where maybe racism is,
is,
is built and,
and,
and we're a little past that,
I think maybe then the,
the power from the word,
the power of the word.
I mean there's still people still alive that had crosses burned in the front of
their house.
Like that's,
I mean,
that word was,
should fear.
Did he really know?
Imagine.
Yeah.
Why would you do that to a Jewish person?
Hey,
have you heard this?
A Phil Ivy Story?
Do you know about the story of Phil Ivey got,
looks like tiger woods.
Phil Ivey is the guy that looks like tiger woods.
He's apparently the best poker player on earth.
And this gentleman,
uh,
went to a British casino and he won $11 million,
11 point $9 million in one spectacular run of a game called Punto Blanco.
It's a buck or rock game.
I don't really know how that,
how that goes,
but he is charged with observing tiny flaws in the games card and then using
that knowledge to give,
give the house a severe thrashing.
He one's like all this money.
When he was down at one point $770,000 he was down.
So he noticed that there was a mark in the cards.
This is the what the casino saying alleging fucked up because he knows the
legend deck game.
I do not know anything about this game.
I know zero about this game,
but I do know that one of the things that they're saying is that he talked the
dealer into not changing the deck.
What stupid that they let them do that.
Okay.
This should never would never flied in Vegas.
They would,
uh,
they would have moved in and going,
what's going on here?
How come you haven't changed that deck?
Yeah.
Like people have developed,
you know,
all sorts of methods of counting cards and they've developed,
developed all these methods of like trying to like control and,
and,
and make rational choices about what's the next car going to be.
So then they figured out how to mitigate that.
They just bring an extra cards.
It put an extra decks.
They throw it all together.
It's the dealers.
Yeah.
They,
um,
apparently so it got this guy got up to some insane amount per bet.
He started at $77,000 per hand and then he raised it with the casinos blessing
up to $230,000 per hand.
Wow Dude.
Stop and think about that cause I was playing 230 and it's apparently again it's
very similar to um,
it's very similar to black jack and and like the odds and how you win and lose.
Like sometimes people do well and sometimes people crash and burn,
but he apparently just pounded on them and they don't want to give him the
money.
But I say like if the guy was down $770,000
one again,
and what kind of a a an advantage does he really have?
You know what,
how come you fucked up then
going on monies.
Monies not even real to him.
See what's making it look realistic.
Like I better used to go down for the next five hands,
you know what I mean?
That's what I would do.
That's a very good one of the 11.9.
He might have that advantage where he can be like,
that is a very good point.
Um,
you know,
that's a big move with pool players,
but that's a move.
Oh Man.
To rake you in.
I mean,
it's a classic move you,
it's from the movie the Hustler.
When Forrest Whitaker place Paul Newman and he acts like a,
uh,
like a mental patient when he first meets him,
he tells him that they did all experiments on them and shit like that.
And then as the game gets better,
they kept forced,
pays him for a bit at first,
and then he starts playing really fucking good.
And he,
that Paul Newman by this time is drunk and he's losing all of his money.
And at the end he bought to give him the money.
He goes,
are you a Hustler Amos?
Are you a hustler?
He goes,
he'll have to pay me,
man.
It's cool.
I mean,
I wanted no bad feelings.
Yeah.
But playing on people's Egos in a pool game is very different than a card game.
There's no playing on the egos here.
We did that.
I told you about why you dump me and my buddy did that in a um,
in upstate New York.
Didn't hustle people.
We were playing this game.
I think I told you about it.
We put two balls in each pocket,
back to back,
three balls in the center and then you get a cue ball to the guy and you say,
all right,
it's five bucks to buy.
If you win,
I'll give you 50.
You've got to run the table.
You can't miss a shot.
And it's him.
It's only four balls.
No,
there's every ball on the table too.
And each pocket you have to shoot two in each box.
You know,
there's,
I set it up like this.
I put two back to back in this pocket.
How many balls are on the table?
Every single box.
Every 15 balls.
15 balls,
three in the center,
two in each pocket.
And I give them the cue ball.
Three in the center,
like lined up in the center.
Do you want him to run them in order or any order?
All you gotta do is not miss.
Just run the table.
It's really difficult.
It's difficult for an average pool player mean probably you could probably do
it.
It just depends on if the balls are broken.
If the balls are broken and there's no clusters,
there's what?
What keeps you from running out?
It's clusters.
So it's like this.
It's like this.
It's like,
like this is the pocket.
There's two balls like this,
right?
Does the pocket,
there's two balls like this.
There's two balls like this.
Okay.
No one knows you're sitting on it and then there's three in the center I think
I,
okay,
so what the thing is is what will happen is if you play with intent and you just
try to tap 'em in and move your ball,
move the cue ball to the next one in,
line up your next shot,
you'll do it.
What happens is you're going to get left with like three balls on the table with
a couple long odd shots.
That sounds like wind.
That's a soccer game.
It definitely was.
You're only saying that you're going to get left with those odd shots.
We don't know how to play it.
The majority.
Yeah,
but that's,
why would they be playing that?
Because it seems it looks so easy.
Me and my buddy easy to run 15 balls.
That's fucking hard.
It's if you ever play straight pool,
straight pools,
essentially the godfather of all pools and with street food,
it's also called 14 one continuous.
That was what they used to play back in the old days when the gentleman gamblers
of like the Hustler era,
they'd play for thousands and thousands of dollars in play street pool.
That was a man's game.
And with straight pool is every ball.
Yeah.
You call every single shot and every ball you,
you can choose any dang stripes are solids,
but at you leave one ball left and you shoot that ball in and the cue ball
smashes the rack and you continue gun.
And there's guys that have run hundreds of hundreds of balls.
Like my friend Max,
I believe he's run 200 balls.
That's like a big number.
Like run out.
I've never run a hundred balls,
but a hundred balls is like when you were a legit straight pool player.
Yeah.
I've never,
I think I've run like 50 maybe more,
maybe a little more,
but that's about it.
I haven't played
in so long.
I used to be really good.
So Eddie and I did this in part in New York.
We needed money.
We were broke and so just started saying,
you know,
we line up the table and some guys,
what are you doing and go,
Hey,
I'm going to try it.
We've known each other five bucks to buy in,
would buy him for five and couldn't do it.
Couldn't do it.
Then he'd bring his friends over.
Couldn't do it was definitely a hustle.
Here's the,
here's the rub is that we couldn't do it either.
Like it was hard to do for us.
That's a way to make money.
If you're a pool player,
it's a better guy that he can't do it because this is most likely not going to
do it that way.
You don't even have to play him.
Exactly.
That's what guys do.
That's called playing the ghost,
but playing the ghost,
you get to break and then you get ball in hand and most people lose.
To the ghost.
The ghost is like say if you wanted to play.
Um,
it's a good way to practice too.
He'd say you're going to play a race to 10.
Okay.
And Raisa 10 for like 1000 bucks and you're going to play the ghost.
That would mean only your playing.
You break the balls and then you get ball in hand and then from there you try to
run out.
If you don't run out,
you lose.
And the ghost wins.
She goes to ghost.
You gotta assume that every time you missed the ghost runs out.
Yeah.
So you break and run out every game and most people lose to the ghost.
Nine ball or April 10 ball.
10 Ball.
Yes.
10 balls.
10 balls,
like nine ball.
But it has an extra ball.
Well,
it's an,
it's an rotation game.
It's the same thing.
It's a rotation game,
meaning you,
you shoot balls one through 10 and you have to make contact with the lowest
number of rack,
10 balls,
you rack them like a mini eight ball rack.
Okay.
Um,
yeah,
that,
that is fascinating.
I,
I used to love,
we had a pool table in her house for a couple of years in college and that's all
we did.
That like what you're doing is like,
it's a really smart thing to do because you don't have any,
when you want,
where you want to do with a person.
If you're playing pool with them and she want to get them to shoot,
if you can get them to shoot,
you can win.
And if you can get them to shoot playing the ghost,
You can,
you can,
you can find a way to win as long as they're shooting.
But when you're shooting
that can lose.
That's where we got caught speaking loose as soon as it was.
These guys were,
these guys were cool and we ended up going to a horse track with them the next
day.
But they were playing over and over again and they were getting pissed because
you get real close but you get close,
you got like three balls left and they're just odd shots and it's a wide open
table.
Now 15 balls is a lot of balls to run.
But it looks don't simple.
The only for idiots.
Yup,
exactly.
So then they said,
fuck you,
this can't be done.
And I'm like,
it can be done.
And I go,
it's,
everything is possible.
I'm just saying it and we tell them at the beginning it's a very hard,
didn't see that's when you need a pro player right next to him who just runs
those balls out.
It makes it look easy.
I did.
And then that you did it,
did it.
And let me tell you something.
I did it done it maybe four times total in my life because we used to do this in
the in our fraternity house all the time and I fucking did it.
And the guy,
I was like,
all right,
I'll show you.
I'll watch.
Let me show you how it's done.
It's very simple,
right?
Start off with a ball in the center,
run one to the side pocket and tap,
tap.
Leave it right up against the other ball.
Then come back the other direction.
A little descriptive for this imaginary game.
It's not really even happening,
but you're doing commentary and a game.
And going out of your head.
Yeah,
so,
but I did it.
I ended up running the table and they were like,
oh.
And then we had him for another fucking 10 rounds because they were like,
all right,
now I gotta fuck.
Now I know how it's done.
Wow,
that seems like a good hustle.
If one's going to steal that,
they're going
to call that the machine hustle.
That's the new machine hustle.
That's a good hustle by the way.
It's a great hustle.
It's a good hustle and you should even let the guy break.
Let a guy break.
Cause especially if by the way,
15 balls,
even if you get to shoot every ball,
whenever we want stripes or solids,
you still have an issue with balls clustering up.
Most people do not know how to break that up.
You don't know how to plan for it.
You don't know how to do it.
You're not.
You're going to get stuck where you got no shot.
That's the odds are much higher.
Like that's a real sucker bet.
The right way to do that.
You should have like five to one on the money.
That's where someone should be saying like you should have to give up five to
ever one that they gather and then they play that you gave them 10 to one.
We said if you hit when we'll give you 50 bucks,
it'd be five to buy in.
Oh my God.
That was how you were doing.
Okay.
That will,
that,
that's even different.
I learned it in Russia.
It was,
it was seven to one.
So seven one five buck by and you walk away with 35 and it was straight pool.
This,
this sees a long time to make money though.
Straight fuels one of them.
You're fine.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
Let me take that back.
Gets out.
Hold on.
It is,
it was,
I take that back.
I think this is what it was third,
cause it's all,
I'm coming to you for facts no matter what from now on fucking,
I'm so unreliable.
It was straight pool slop counted and it you gotta you gotta uh,
a dollar percentage.
Every time you sunk a ball for every ball you got,
it was $35 to buy in.
And then everything over that you got to keep and,
but I didn't realize the first time I played I was calling shots and I was with,
my dad got Igor and he was watching me and I was calling shots and he's like,
you don't need to call the shots when you were playing in Russia,
in Russia,
when I was in Russia,
we went to a,
they have a different game over there,
right?
They have Russian billiards.
It was a huge fucking table.
Huge table.
I want to say it was more than,
I want to say it was more balls,
but it was basically,
it was straight pool.
Now that you said it,
I'd never played the game before.
Maybe I'm wrong because I thought they'd mostly played like Russian billiards
over there,
but I've never been there.
So yeah,
it was,
no,
it was one huge table.
They have a different game though,
and it was just,
and it was like you buy in against the house,
you buy a dollar percentage and then every ball you hit in,
you earn a dollar percentage back.
So it's like every ball is worth five bucks.
I'm giving you a numbers,
it's $35 to buy in.
Every is worth five bucks.
So if you six,
seven balls,
you're,
you're in the break.
And then if you run the rest of the table,
you do it.
So we do you get extra money.
So the first time we did it,
I was calling shots and,
and I missed,
I lost my money.
The other guy went in,
he was the,
the guy that worked there who did this against everyone and he started fucking
running the table,
but he slopped counted.
He didn't have to call any fucking shots.
So I said to Igor,
I go,
hold on.
You can just fucking,
he was doing those,
you know,
when you run the pool cue through and it's just out ball start running
everywhere.
He was doing that.
And so,
uh,
I said to you where I go,
that's bullshit.
And he goes,
Oh yeah,
you don't have to call him.
He just had a men.
So I was like,
oh fuck.
Is this the game that you saw?
It's like,
it's Russian billiards.
It looks like it's a sneaker table and they're all white balls.
It was probably drunk and it was
like 1520 years ago.
Okay.
You don't remember?
I may have a,
they have a weird game,
but they may have been
play over there.
It's like pool on a snooker table with big balls and all the balls are white.
It's really,
yeah.
Is it straight pool where you just run the table?
Oh Man.
I don't know anything about the rules of Russian billiards,
but Russians is just such a strange group of white people.
They're the strangest motherfuckers man.
But the point of the point of the ego story is I started really like hamming it
up and doing the Tom Cruise from color of money.
Samurai chops with the pool cue did.
Yeah.
I was like really fucking to spend that or pull me aside.
He was like,
time to start losing.
And I was like,
what?
And I realize I'm winning money at a bar with a bunch of fucking gangsters.
Oh yeah.
And he was like,
just lose.
Just lose them.
Let's go home.
And I was like,
ah,
fuck it.
All my money.
Sometimes you got to lose to walk out and win because they,
what are you?
He goes,
I'm not going to bring over to the tech to you.
You've got a bunch of fucking cat rubles in your pocket.
You're walking out like a fucking lot American.
Yeah.
You don't want to be doing it like I'm fucking Tom Cruise.
Such a pain.
I was drunk when he too.
I would never go with you to another country.
Oh fucking come on.
Ever.
I would be a blast up until the point where we get shot.
That guy doesn't exist anymore.
This is a bag over.
Our heads were in the back of a truck bounce around through the desert.
Joe,
can you hear me?
You're chokes.
Fucking sock.
We stopped with that shit.
You fucked with those people in a truck.
So this Phil Ivey
Ivy game.
Apparently it was the same game that a James Bond played.
Punto Blanco Bonko bonkers.
It's like white horse.
It's a sister game of oh,
okay.
It's assisted game of Kim and defer the game that preferred by James Bond Shemen
Shemen differ.
C,
h e,
the,
the high stakes game preferred by James Bond.
If he was real.
Yeah.
So I don't know what the fuck's going to happen.
The they,
they,
oh,
this dude a shitload of money.
They owed him millions of dollars.
So it's going to be interesting to see if they can prove that he was doing that
or if he just got fucking lucky.
Well,
there's no way to prove it now,
right?
I Dunno man.
They,
they have the deck.
I mean they,
they're able to withhold the money,
which I think is hilarious.
It's like that,
that in and of itself,
that's like a violation of the contract that you made when you went in.
If you can't prove that someone's cheating and they won,
yeah.
It's up to you to prove it before you withhold money.
You can't just say,
you think that he was doing this.
So you think that maybe the symmetrical cards or perhaps it's asymmetrical if
you coming up with a bunch of reasons why you think that this guy stole money
from you.
But that's a weird thing to just allow this company because it has so much
money.
It allow them to just steal money when they feel like they were fucked.
Whereas almost everybody goes in there,
feels like they were fucked and no one cares.
And when,
when ivy was down 770,000 what if he and said,
you know what?
I think this game is rigged and a,
I'm not paying you until I go to court.
What if every time someone lost money,
it was that same arrangement.
You would go bankrupt.
They would go bankrupt because everybody would do it.
Everybody would dispute it.
Because if you,
if you win or they give up,
you don't have to pay.
But if you lose,
you have to pay.
So everybody would try to dispute it in court if,
if everybody could do what they're doing,
what they're doing is unbelievably douchey.
Casinos exist to lose money or to make money.
They exist.
So other people lose money.
And if other people stop losing money,
they're fucked.
Their business models a mess.
So their business model is inequality,
their business model ripping you off.
I mean it's,
it's the most ridiculous shit ever.
It's like the only way they can have these giant buildings is if you fucking
lose.
And if you win,
they can boot you out.
Like there's a reason why the UFC doesn't go back to the palms cause cause Dana
white wiped him out.
He plays high stakes blackjacks and he wiped them out and the next time he went
back they tried to give him half the,
uh,
the credit limit because if he only has half the credit,
can't,
he can't come back.
Can't come back.
Like the whole idea about blackjack and gambling is you gotta be ready to go
into a deep hole in order to win a lot of money.
You gotta be prepared to lose a lot of money.
And Dana's last as much as a million dollars in a night.
I said he's one of those scary guys to them.
How's he goes in?
I don't know.
I don't understand.
We had him in here and respectfully because I love him and he's my brother.
I tried to suggest that maybe yes,
brain damage.
It's true.
There's a connection.
I know that he's been at a lot of fights.
I know,
first of all,
I grew up in Boston.
I know that he was a boxer.
I know that he hadn't been nears disease from a beating that he took one night
by a bunch of guys.
So I know that he's been in a lot of fights and there's a direct correlation
that they've recently established between people that have a certain type of
brain damage and compulsive gambling.
Well,
let's be real candid though,
like Dana,
the kind of guy that is Dana white is also the kind of guy that is Charles
Barkley and Michael Jordan.
Michael Jordan,
like these,
it's a guy that made magic happen,
made magic with his life happening on the paper.
He was not supposed to end up already is today.
Okay.
But he did it.
So there's very different between him and those two guys because those two guys
were athletes and those two guys did it with,
uh,
with natural athletic performances.
When he did it with,
he was the perfect guy and the perfect time to run a business.
That's that crazy.
Yeah.
You know,
to not try to water it down in any way,
shape or form to actually embrace the,
the aggressive aspects of it and exemplify them.
And that's,
that's a,
that's a weird thing about who he is.
Cause like no CEOs,
whatever it behave like him,
the way he behaves,
he's crazy as fights and people on Twitter go fuck your mother.
I mean she's a mad maybe the slim Jim I told,
I told the president travels handle she needed to slap slap chop guy.
Is that what you meant?
The snappiness Lindzen oh that's a rightie.
Macho man.
Savage.
Yeah.
Maybe he's got a job though.
See Dana bridges the gap between being a
man's man and being a businessman.
Like he knows how to do business as well,
but he doesn't give a fuck,
you know?
And now that he's got a lot of money,
it gives even less of a fuck.
I told the president of travel channel at dinner that night that she needed to
run Twitter just like Dana White and be like,
I dunno about this fucking Adam Richmond guy.
What do you guys think?
It doesn't really run it like fucking Dana white like big bird guides.
And she really is.
I go,
who'd be so fucking funny you should do is offer right at four and say,
listen,
I try and manage your life.
They said no fucking way.
I was like,
let me run travel channel.com for like for like the Twitter handle for one day,
one hour for one day.
We'll,
we'll,
we'll come on the podcast and promote it and we'll just attack.
All right everybody,
everybody,
this is what we,
okay.
Tweet Nisha.
Spell it.
She's,
she's the one who uh,
who runs travel channel.
I maybe I shouldn't say that,
but it demand Rachael Ray nip slips.
No,
Nisha create those with,
with digital.
That'll be one of the first scandals when an act,
an act actress accidentally has a nip slip and she goes,
that never fucking happened.
Like,
oh well we've kind of on filming.
So unfortunate.
And it turns out some creepy editor faked in and nip slip
tweet at n.
I.
S h.
She is,
uh,
she's my,
she was like,
does all the media for travel channel through the Internet and tell her that I
should run travel channels.
Twitter for one day.
There's a,
she's on,
she's on the fence about it.
So if everyone tweets or then she'll be like,
oh fuck,
there's a,
maybe this will be fun,
chartered and neither of you,
it's never gonna happen.
Let it go because she's not going to want you to go through her all her private
messages and see like her sporting network travel channel.
It's not hers.
It's not gonna give me hers.
Welcome to Burt's courts.com.
Thank you for signing up for your membership guys.
You get one damp Bert cleanup cloth.
No one email or no one tweeter.
This is a bad idea guys.
Come on.
I'm a professional man.
Can't have put it back in the box.
The box.com can't have it both ways.
God,
I should've never get lettered Twitter.
I noticed something weird about Vancouver when we were up there.
I was,
there was so many Chinese people there cause we got the story of Asians people.
Period.
Did you ever go to that museum up there?
No,
but the driver was telling us about how,
you know,
they all moved up there like all these really rich Chinese people that come up
with in the fifties or sixties well yeah,
miss of complicated immigration story probably wouldn't,
shouldn't simplify it like that.
There's actually a whole library we can go a I went with,
I think I was already maybe Dunkin,
I forget who else was up there with me.
We're working but we went to this uh,
immigration library.
This a Chinese or a museum rather.
There's a Chinese like immigration museum.
It was pretty interesting.
Like just the history of Vancouver.
That's bad ass fucking town man.
Well I was trying to theirs,
it was so,
so much beautiful women because there's so many
Asian girls and stuff out there and I tried to find a massage parlor and I went
like three hours,
like walking around and trying to find one.
There was not one anywhere near there.
Then I notice like the strip clubs,
like,
like they had really weird things going on with the strip clubs.
Like you can't touch the girls are
but on people.
Well,
I'm just saying and then I went to,
uh,
look for boner pills because I like to take it on stage.
When I had to do this bit about boner pills and like show people and stuff,
I went to maybe five,
seven,
11 is like every single little market.
Finally I just went to the guy,
I'm like,
look,
I'm a comic.
They have these things.
I explained it to him,
uh,
of this convenience store and he goes,
no way,
dude.
They don't sell that shit here in Canada.
And I would just seem like Canada's seemed really a censored in some ways.
And then that's fine.
Boner pills,
right.
I came in,
I didn't find any jerk off haulers and uh,
there was no boner pills.
What a bullshit country.
The whole country basically is bullshit.
The city,
the city of Vancouver seems you were in a really weird,
you were in an unusual area.
Okay.
You were in a very nice area and a very specific area.
I mean to say that that's the whole area.
That's a whole town.
It's kind of silly.
You saw a small part and mostly a high traffic business and tourist destination
as well.
You know,
just because they don't that those fucking pills are not good for you man.
You think it's okay to just throw back these fucking boner pills every week and
not have any problems they,
they're not necessarily good for you man.
What are you doing Brian?
You at?
You showing off all your heart on pills.
If the gold one,
this is the black ones,
will you take,
you should get go to a doctor and tell me Dick's broken and it give you a
Viagara because that's what that is.
You're eating Viagara you just,
you're just getting it through some dick up regularly.
Oh no I can't.
It's broken.
It's Dick's Bro.
He totally,
why do you dread wired it?
Because then you have boners for like days.
It's fine.
I don't need it for days.
I need it for like 20 minutes.
You say it now have you tatted voter for days it's fine.
I don't know if I want a boat over days.
But did you see that?
Like how do you think is Canada?
Do you even realize what you're saying?
Yeah,
I did.
I couldn't find any boner pills or powders and you couldn't touch it,
which is normal.
They don't sell the boner pills.
Uh,
and the massage part is like the REC.
Yeah.
Was only like a couple here.
They're trying to get rid of them and so in that town,
but that's because we're saving Coover in,
in that area.
That part of town that we were at.
I mean there's areas where you can go out where it's like they're very young and
basically my prostitution.
Yeah.
But massage parlors,
all of them like,
well,
they're trying to keep,
they try to keep those things out of nice areas,
bro.
You can't find one in Beverly Hills.
Go to Beverly Hills and try to find a place that beats you off.
No,
I'm not saying a beat up place.
I'm talking to like legit massage parlors.
Most of those are not legit.
Like if you drive down,
if you drive down Santa Monica,
pass the four oh five,
you're going to run into a bunch.
But not that I know,
but I'm just saying that's what I hear.
Yeah.
But whatever.
These also don't make you come,
Huh?
These also,
uh,
are for premature ejaculation.
Yeah.
They totally,
it's like,
oh no,
what am I done?
You can pound it forever.
Hey,
did you see that photo that the Australian dude put took the paraglider took of
a,
a vortex in Australia?
Why?
It's on my Twitter.
You got to see this.
This is insane.
This guy took this photo when he was paragliding and it's one of those things in
those movies that suck ships into it and brings it down to the bottom of the
ocean.
The ocean.
Oh,
shut.
No more taxes.
Well,
he got a photo of an actual vortex and it's fucking beautiful,
man.
It's just slightly off shore and he's a paragliding over it and it looks like a
hurricane that's happening in the ocean,
like a hurricane that's happening of water.
You see a Brian?
It's the one on the Huffington Post.
Yes.
Yeah.
Pull this up.
Check this out,
man.
Bro,
do you read it?
What are you trying to get up to your Twitter to find that picture so I can
fucking down.
Look,
it's up over there.
You don't have to turn around.
There's two TVS.
Just one over that Eiko Fella.
That's beautiful man.
He was on paraglider.
Yeah.
Oh that's scary shit.
He's gangster cause you just find it.
Well that you don't know what that does to the fucking pressure system.
[inaudible] be so weird.
Well,
you know,
that's one of the theories about the Bermuda triangle.
The Bermuda triangle is like a legit mystery.
And one of the,
one of the theories about the Bermuda triangle is a certain amount of
underground gas getting released.
I think it's nitrogen.
Oh fuck.
I forget what the gas it is.
I shouldn't say whatever the gas is not as would makes sense.
Cause then that would cut engines.
I think that's what it is.
And it's under the underground in massive pockets of like decaying seaweed and
stuff like that.
And apparently when it bursts,
it goes through the water,
rises up into the atmosphere and it kills a plane's ability to fly because it's,
it's like a big giant cloud.
So these planes nose dive and then when it hits boats,
like the nitrogen rich water,
when it hits
both,
they just sink.
I see someone who's obsessed with the Bermuda triangle when I was a kid,
big foot Bermuda triangle,
fucking horses.
Lat doesn't have anything to do with each other and precious gems.
What the fuck those or do you remember the show?
Do you remember the big flood angel?
I just,
anything that had like some like through the member that's figuring and horses
where they'd be.
Let's talk about this,
cause I'm going looking for bigfoot with Dunkin this week.
Are you fucking serious?
We're gone from my new shot.
We're going looking for bigfoot.
Oh,
we're going into like known habitat's going happy.
Hilarious.
Do you find them and then it's like all these years you just needed to go out
and take three day vacation and find them.
There's something going on,
there's something going on.
Do you know how many pissed off bigfoot hundreds.
Well this is,
this is what's going on
with the whole big foot thing.
There's this,
someone has to decide.
Someone has to investigate what's going on cause it's even there's this
possibilities that it's real,
but there's is that everyone is losing their mind,
including me for going and looking for this fucking thing.
No,
I don't think this is,
this is,
this is what fucking need to do with their lives.
No.
It could be some sort of a mass hysteria type thing.
I don't think it is.
But I think to approach any unusual suspect,
no matter what you would like it to be.
Of course I would like to go there and see big foot.
Of course.
I would like to go there and get convincing video and photographs and,
and sounds of bigfoot of course.
But I've got to really be honest.
There is a possibility it doesn't exist.
And all these people that have told me it exists,
I have no reason to disbelieve them.
The people that have told me they've had experiences,
But I have not had those experiences myself.
So even if I do believe them and trust them 100% I still don't 100% know that
it's real.
Are you bringing any technology with you?
Oh God.
So you believe in the culinary man.
We're going to look at it from overhead with a blimp.
Infrared and now we're gonna.
We're gonna figure out a bunch of different ways when we might go twice.
We're going to go this time and then I'm going to try to go in July with Les
Stroud.
I'm going to go back with survivor.
Man.
We're going to go one and we're gonna Talk Shit on bear.
Bear Grylls the whole time we're there.
Fucking hotel stamp bitch when we're out there roughing it with it.
Sticks up our ass sleeping in tents,
bear Grylls and lounge at the four seasons slippers on.
Watching pay per view that fuck.
When you were a kid,
did you watch,
did you watch the show?
Big Foot in search of with Leonard Nimoy?
Yeah.
Big Foot and wild boy I to,
I was obsessed with that show.
You probably got dropped in your head or something?
I probably do cloth until I was in a fucking second grade.
Every single day when I got to play loincloth and moccasins,
I went camping with my family when I was probably like
probably 10 ish somewhere around then.
And uh,
we were up in the northern California area and I ran into a trapper and a guy
like gave me like,
it was pretty gross and all that,
thinking about it,
it gave me like a real rabbit's foot.
It was like a fucking rabbit.
It's,
it started rotting,
it stunk.
It was nasty.
Kept in a paper bag and I opened the bag and I'm like,
Jesus Christ,
Bob gimme a bobcat foot.
It's kind of fucked up when I think about it because,
you know,
the guy was like,
essentially it was killing these animals and cutting of skin off.
And that's how he made a living.
And it was really,
it's really weird if you stop,
I'm thinking drivers are creepy.
It's a weird way to make a living man.
You know,
I,
and I'm not,
I'm not for it,
but here's the,
here's the thing.
When you look at like someone who kills Minx,
it's like you're,
you're killing an animal only for its skin.
You're not really going to eat it.
It's not like it's a buffalo and you're going to get both out of it.
You're only actively going after this animal for its skin.
That's kind of a fucked up thing.
It's a serial killers do that with humans.
It's kind of a fucked up thing.
But what's the thing,
the other thing to consider is,
well,
if you don't,
what does,
what's the life expectancy of these animals?
It's very small.
It's very short.
And if you don't kill them,
it's very likely that some wolf is going to come along and kill them or some
coyote or whatever.
So the real question becomes,
do you deserve to be the person,
be the,
the,
the being that kills this for a different desire.
Your desire is to have it enhance your artificially created culture,
life you to take the skin from this animal and turn it into currency and in
order to,
you know,
it's again to help you,
enable you to live like a better life.
Or is it only reserved for wolves?
Deet?
It's so weird little situation because no,
no fucking minks die of old age,
you know,
and make it to old age man.
Nobody makes it to old age.
He fuck as much as you can.
You make as many babies as you can and you gotta be confident in the fact that
most likely a lot of people you know are going to get eaten by wolves for your
mink.
Fear for years is how long it makes Lyft.
Yeah,
and they make it an either you're not making it to four and I don't want to be
the one who kills a mink for it's for.
But when you look at the real situation,
it's not quite as simple as a person shouldn't be able to do that because
there's people that live in like say let's go talk about like the people that
live in the taiga,
they live in Siberia and that's how their family has been making a living for
generation after generation because it makes you uncomfortable.
It should.
They be forced to stop doing that because that's like a giant percentage of
their income.
Like what they use to buy snowmobiles and what they used to buy tools.
It's like this weird hunting and gathering culture that lives in Siberia and the
Taiga forest and these people,
they need those minx.
They need those whatever the animals that are trapping,
they need those furs and they,
it's not just their family,
their generation after generation has been trapping and hunting.
That's,
that's how they live up there.
So who's to say that they can't do it?
Well,
if they can do it,
who's buying their first?
Well people down here behind the people in Beverly Hills or buying some furs
that came right out of stripe.
Siberia.
And that is how those people are,
are able to survive.
So it's a tricky situation.
It's not quite as simple to me as a cut and black,
you know,
black and white.
You should not be able to do that.
We as a society should stop that because it's evil and the stealing of fur and
skin from an animal and killing it because of that.
It's really gross and vile.
And I agree with that.
I completely agree with that.
But I also realistically look at the situation and go,
well these are,
these are not,
animals are gonna live forever.
You know,
this is,
this is a weird existence.
This thing has its living in this frozen Tundra and everywhere it goes,
something's looking to eat it.
It's like,
oh listen to you going to want to fox to eat it or a wolf,
eat it in two weeks and then we don't get suffer.
I watched one of them was,
um,
Hawaii,
Alaska shows and uh,
they caught a links in a trap.
It's a link.
Oh,
is that like a black cat to fucking cat that lives in Alaska?
It's like this crazy looking giant house cat looking thing with these wild ears.
It's a nasty animal,
man.
I don't want to fucking domesticate one of those.
You don't?
What are you talking about?
You're on the road all the time and have that thing live around your kids.
He crazy.
You never domesticate a wild animal.
You don't domesticate wild animals.
Oh,
look at that.
Look at that.
Cool.
Savannah,
have you seen the Savannah cats?
Yeah.
Anna cats.
Things called against Vangol.
What are they called?
It's an her serve all serve all in the house.
Cat.
It's a Savannah,
Savannah cat.
Those are bad ass.
A buddy who has one,
he says it gives it a chicken legs and it growls at them.
Shut up.
He says when he gives a chicken legs,
it goes wow.
He says it eats it and makes these crazy amazing
third grader.
I would not let that thing hang with my kids.
10 of them in my backyard.
I live on top of a mountain in Ohio's fucking cow and they fucking roam outdoors
and rattlesnakes and shit.
What?
I have chickens,
I mean event chickens for the last few months.
And uh,
I can let my dogs around the chickens but I can't let my cat get out.
And my cat,
he stands outside the window and sees the chickens and goes like,
it
really is a mouse start shaking cause he's like,
cause his jaw is quivering because all he's thinking about doing is taking life.
That's all I can think about is watch these little chicks tweet,
tweet,
tweet walking around and he just wants to bum rush them and just steal on him
and just rip them apart.
And all of his instincts are just fighting it off.
You can't stop that.
You can't prevent a cat from doing that.
You can't train it out of them,
but you can't.
A dog like my massive,
I'm sure he would want to kill those things,
but I show him,
I'm like,
Hey,
easy,
easy buddy and his tails wag.
And he's like,
okay so don't kill him.
Go,
go kill him.
And I totally trust him.
I don't trust my cat or cats at that cow with Venetia and that fucking bad ass.
You know those things are unpredictable,
man.
I don't,
I don't know what the behavior patterns of those things are,
but I've got to think that it's a bad idea to bring in a half a wild anything.
I have a friend of mine's huskies.
I have a friend.
No,
no,
no.
Husky is a breed.
The big difference between a Husky looks like a wolf.
It's a breed.
But I have a friend that has three seven eighth Timberwolves.
Seven eighth.
Yes,
there's seven ace Timberwolf and one [inaudible].
No,
he does not have kids but he's got a weird situation,
you know.
And I told them,
I'm like,
dude,
you're barely in control of this household.
Like he's got a big male and the big male is totally dominant.
The big male.
In fact God out once it killed his neighbor sheep like you had like a,
it's got a wolf.
He lives with a wolf.
He's one thunder storm away from a fucking coup d'etat.
Exactly.
I'm not cool with one Zombie apocalypse.
Zombies will never get to him.
Cause the wolves will eat him as soon as they go hungry.
As long as they run out of canned
dog food and dry food and you can't go outside,
the wolves are going to look at them and go,
okay,
yeah,
you can't take care of us anymore,
bitch.
This agreement that we have,
yeah,
we're going to have to let that go.
He's got a 200 pound both in his house.
200 pounds is a big fucking animal.
It's enormous.
Do Art.
Priscilla's 130 pounds and I imagine it might not be 200 pounds.
It's at least one 50 it.
It's a giant monster.
My my massive is one 40 and it was way bigger than my mastiff is way bigger,
way taller.
It's a big animal.
Like I remember coming over his house and was like,
dude,
this is ridiculous.
Like you got a weird situation here and like when you make this noise,
you go like this.
Whew.
The dogs would go,
they would start howling and you realize right away,
these are not dogs,
man.
They look a little like dog.
You don't have dogs.
You got fucking wild animals in your house.
It is amazing that we have domain over them.
He barely had domain.
Let me tell you something.
This dude is barely keeping it together and he would like I said,
like the got out and they,
they killed a number of sheep.
It was yes.
It wasn't like he killed one cheap and was satisfied and it,
no,
he went on a murderous,
exactly.
I'm murderer list salt.
Yeah.
That was a reality show.
It was a neighbor's ranch and the neighbor,
you know,
it was furious and came over and he denied it and the whole thing,
you got to protect his dog's name.
Neighbor came over to the shore fucking shotgun and he's kind of a con for not
telling the truth.
I mean,
you got to man up.
You want to be a bad ass and have a fucking pet wolf.
Well,
when the wolf kills 18 sheep,
whatever the hell it did,
can he just go with it was eight or 18 one of those.
Either one is equally impressive.
Let's take it once you've killed eight.
Let's go with eight.
Eight to fucking think about how much time it takes to kill eight things with
your face.
Just run around jacket eight sheet.
It's ripping throat.
That will
kill one cheap with your face.
No,
no.
A lot of work.
I could pretend to kill it.
My face.
I'd have it in a rear naked and then I would like go sideways and pretend to be
biting the juggler,
but real,
I'd kill it with a rear naked start.
The time he could get around it.
You could get around a sheep's neck and put it out.
You get,
but the thing is not going to struggle.
It just doesn't until it starts.
Once you have your hooks in,
it doesn't matter.
Our struggle all day.
Do you have your hooks in?
It's not going anywhere.
Fucking sheep doesn't know.
No defense.
Sheep doesn't even have any hands.
She'd can't go two on one.
She can't get us an arm bar.
It's going out.
Fucking sheep's going out.
They were talking,
they were talking about,
I was watching something where someone got caught in an exotic pet fighting
ring.
It's a new show on to new shows on TV.
I just saw the promo for it,
Exxon.
It's called Tarzan.
Oh,
fucking stupid name.
Tarzan.
Don't they know there's a whole book and movie series with that same name?
You confuse the shit out of people,
but can you see if you can find that?
It's not like our tone and the talk show host goes in.
I mean that was his fucking name.
Okay.
The guy's name is Tarzan.
Fuck that guy.
They were like,
he goes in and he finds an exotic pet fighting ring and I'm like,
if he found that,
we would have heard about,
but that by now,
not necessarily.
It could have been a [inaudible] ring.
No,
Jesus Christ.
That's a city.
I think it's an also the problem is that like they could have created that
themselves just to make a TV show about it.
That's super possible.
Some of those shows I'm like,
fucking seriously,
how do we have clean audio?
I want to do that.
Just walked up to Obar.
Yeah.
Hopefully I go,
look,
we've do shows where we're all miked and we don't get clean audio.
Like,
I can't believe that we're going to in mystery diners that we have guide that's
eating a sandwich that was rubbed on the girl's tit and we got clean audio on
them.
Where's the fucking mic?
Where's the mic thrown on the table?
I don't buy it as a lot of that.
A lot of fuckery isn't foot.
What does that guy or that girl rescues parents.
As long as you don't take that parrot outside your house on your shoulder
because if you do,
you're an asshole.
Urban Tarzan's.
Is it urban towards hassle,
trying to take something out of Twitter.
No more.
S.
M.
H.
What was it?
No more.
Shut my head.
Stop.
What was the stop and you don't think that Jesus was the person.
Say Yourself.
Smh,
SMH.
Shake my head.
I can't believe it.
And it's almost universally used by idiots.
Put SMH,
especially men.
You're a grown man.
You put s m h at the end of your tweet.
I hope that kills your boner for a month while you just rethink your life.
S M,
a.
H you fucks.
I look at this website for that.
That show that Bert was talking about like,
look,
this locked into cars truck.
Yeah,
look,
it's a bobcat dude.
You do not want to fuck with the movies have taken over what star and the
enquirer wants where those are.
They now create programming that is,
the guy's got allotted as fuck and it's like a bobcat was caught in the trunk.
It's was just one step away from aliens.
Got My daughter pregnant.
Well,
I think that it's just,
there's money in it.
And as soon as there's money in creating fake TV,
people let go.
Well,
wait a minute,
it's okay to make a sitcom,
but it's not okay to take a bunch of people that actually do work in an auto
garage and make a bunch of fake scenarios and they actually tried half and a
half unique person.
But why does it drive you nuts?
Okay.
Because it's not mean if once you establish what it is,
it's just a show.
Because,
um,
well I'll say this from my perspective.
I watched duck dynasty,
the people that,
first of all,
how fucking dare you,
what?
You're a standup comedian.
Do you have a wife,
you have children,
you have things to do and you're watching duck dynasty.
I got 40 minutes of my life digit shit away.
I was on the road,
whatever.
Write a joke bitch.
And I'm watching it by weight.
Completely hypocritical and guilty as charged and watch duck dynasty all the
time.
Someone told me,
they're like,
you gotta watch it.
It's,
it gets me like network numbers.
It's not good.
It's,
here's my thing.
I don't mind a fake reality show if it's a nod to a fake reality show,
but the fact that you're trying to fool me,
pisses me off.
And what sucks is distinctly on trip flip.
I have fought like tooth and nail to make sure that all our crashes are real,
but they look fake as fuck.
When I watched them,
I go,
that doesn't look like we really crashed it,
but we really,
I'm standing on the street corner just like a real person.
But then you want to duck dynasty and people are willing to go,
guys,
I was thinking we'd all go to Hawaii.
Well,
Hey,
I don't even want to go to Hawaii.
Well,
what are we going to do?
Don't worry.
I'll plan it all.
And then he watches it blowing in your face.
It's Sitcom writing.
That's why Dunkin refuse to go on.
Uh,
the minding the store reality show.
Like he knew they were going to make him do something along those lines.
And uh,
he was like,
yeah,
you know what?
I would rather not be on TV.
Boom.
This is what I'm looking for this week.
Bert Kreischer I'm looking for Sasquatch.
Oh,
I could go on squatch and sign me.
I can do it.
Trust five foot nine,
one of those,
me and Duncan Trussell or squatch.
That's fucking great.
We're going out paired again,
go daily board or be prepared to maybe make medical science history.
Maybe bring some mushrooms or something.
They actually,
bigfoot needed with someone like me to come along.
Maybe bigfoot is tired of these fucking dorks out there.
Wander around these unfuckable dorks baby.
The big foot needs someone to talk to.
Maybe bigfoot was like,
man,
listen,
I was kind of reveal myself,
but these guys are douchebags to the route here with fucking wooden beads on.
And you know what the best thing about the show is going to be jail.
You don't listen in to Bert Kreischer talk our guests.
No.
No,
you have to say is more important.
How dare you go ahead Brian.
You know what the best part of the show is going to be is that like if you take
t takes Tom's girl to go hunt for loch ness monster and scuba gear and he's got
audio,
he's going to skate scared as shit cause he's a regular person.
That's going to be fucking awesome.
Yeah,
but what's not going to be awesome?
We're not going to find the fucking lock.
Does it matter?
What would you like to go on?
If you could pack one thing I actually like,
I don't think anyone really believes that there is a big scraped.
Right.
But what do you think is most likely if I gave you a couple scenarios?
Big Squirting.
No,
that's not a good one.
Okay.
Not even remotely feel much macabre.
You if you had to choose,
if you had a possibility,
would it be sick,
toxic,
uh,
in Japan.
Oh,
okay.
Nuclear waste.
But that's another way.
That's not a question.
Yeah,
that's,
yeah,
that's a real issue.
Yeah.
People that have,
they're in Japan.
That's it.
If you've ever seen those Geiger counter videos.
Yeah.
Really fascinating stuff because there's a completely different rating reading
when you have it and you're holding it up in the air as opposed to when you put
it down on the ground,
when it touches the ground,
like they show like safe levels in the air and they touch down in the ground and
this
one guy on his Geiger counter,
it's gone off,
man.
It's like reaching these like really dangerous levels and all these fucking
people are living there.
Have you seen the Google maps?
Uh,
like they just sent a car through it that the driving thing.
So now you can go on maps.google.com and you can do just like dry or do the the,
the map,
the moving map thing and look at all the abandoned houses and all the stores are
just like a ghost town.
It's really true.
Have you seen the videos where they show the street like,
like moving and breaking up where the ocean is underneath the street?
No.
It's like,
oh my God,
what's this?
After the tsunami they changed the,
the whole,
the,
the like the topography and the streets have a real issue with like giving and
they move back and forth and water comes out of cracks.
Like it still looks like streets and there's stills houses on it.
But it is,
it's a movable things.
You have the,
you have,
you're the one of the few people in the world that I know that has a list of the
most amazing things you've ever seen on the Internet.
You should do a show like toss point.
Oh,
but instead of showing people falling and getting hurt,
just fucking shit.
That's awesome.
That you found on the Internet.
Wouldn't be hard to do.
I'd fuck it.
Like every time you tweet something like,
has anyone seen this?
I'm like,
I was going to be fucking awesome.
Well,
one of the things about me retweeting a lot of things is that people will tweet
me a lot of cool shit.
So like,
dude,
the reason why I can tweet all this stuff,
it's because people are constantly sending it to me knowing that if they send me
something cool,
I'll retweet it.
The wolves going after the dude in Russia.
Yeah.
The Guy,
the guy,
the cop sitting there and he's like,
no.
And then he hops in the car with a wolves running down the street.
That wasn't a real,
the what?
Yeah,
it was artificial.
So many made that it's amazing how good it looks.
Yeah,
it's a scam.
Looked amazing.
Wait,
Brian might be wrong.
I mean,
someone,
someone might have called it a hoax and it's not,
let's look up.
What was your answer?
What was it?
What was that?
Have you seen the hoax hold on.
Wolves,
cop car,
Russia
hoax.
We'll just go look up that.
We'll look up that.
And,
and someone tweet me right now.
What is the key?
It stairwell down a second
dude.
It's there.
These are parents are saying it's not fake.
I've doesn't look fake.
Yeah.
It didn't look fake to me,
but some people claim that there was like some,
um,
there was like some like aberration and the video and then if you analyze the
video,
but every youtube video looks like shit.
The checkout at the screen.
This is someone say it is fake though.
This is a,
that ghost town that you know that you could just drive around this whole thing.
Um,
does anyone know the name of that p that stairwell where it's an infant
stairwell where it just goes round in a circle and that one guy's hosting it.
Have you seen that kit is a kit?
What are you talking about?
Say it again.
Um,
this is creepy.
There's a stairwell that it goes around in as you,
as you walk up,
you also then,
okay.
Show,
do you know what I'm talking about?
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
Keep going.
Am I talking about,
Oh,
I know what you're talking.
Keep calling
K I t right.
That was this [inaudible].
What is that?
Is that a hoax or is that real?
I don't know.
Have you seen the video?
I think so,
but they're seen so much.
It's getting,
it's getting tricky.
I'll fall asleep if I could.
That commercial the though
we saw though the wolf I'm running down the street apparently is a voce
commercial.
It's a part of a Vod for commercial.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Yeah.
All right.
I don't know if that's true though.
I'm looking at it right now.
Yup.
Yeah,
they set it up.
Okay.
They're showing,
the setup is showing,
there's sewing.
A camera's booing moving in place that she has fake.
They have people working there and then they added the wolves to it added the
wolves with CGI.
But the reality of Russia is perfect.
Ugly.
What's the perfect ugliest?
Just tweeted me the fucking video.
The reality of Russia.
Have you heard about these?
A Siberian super packs of wolves?
I have.
That's why I thought that was real.
It's not,
but it could be the what?
What is real is way scarier than that.
Cause what?
What that is is a standard pack,
but what they've got in Siberia,
because of these record cold temperatures is packs up 400 wolves,
Roman together and decimating livestock.
They're coming over fences to attack sheep and they're just slaughtering
everything.
That's what that is.
What that the fact that that exists.
It was what makes game of Thrones so fucking real for me.
Oh yeah.
Look,
we're,
we are just protected or protected by technology.
It Brian Rit,
stairwell rit.
In four days these wolves in Siberia killed 30 horses.
Yeah,
30 horses in four days.
That's a scary place to be,
man.
Could you imagine if you lived on,
it's like getting caught by a swarm of bees.
Swarm of killer bees.
Damn.
That is the thing.
Like I know you're a game of Thrones fan also,
like when you went on,
I'll just go back a couple of,
so it's not a spoiler for anyone.
How dare you.
Don't even do it.
Yeah.
Okay.
People Dvr.
What if they're deployed?
Do you have hate for the troops?
Okay guys,
so you could always do what do you hate?
The truth.
Okay,
let's go back.
Let's go when they killed Robb stark.
How dare you.
Oh my God.
You fucking [inaudible] man.
What if you start watching it?
Are you you fuck.
Can we not talk about games of Thrones?
It's the fucking greatest show on TV.
Did Tony Soprano die or did he not die at the end of the fucking series?
Look,
watch this.
Watch this.
Watch.
This is the rit.
Our period I interior,
very tasty designed by Filipino architects.
Rafael Nelson.
I'm Lagonda was built in 1968 and has been wowing rit students ever since.
One of the coolest things is Google,
that guy's name,
them experience that for the first time here.
It's Rafael Lagonda.
I'd make that grow.
I saying that correctly.
Okay.
Hockeytech Rafaella Vonda a Grad student in what program?
Yep.
Uh,
okay.
So,
uh,
have you been here before to the sterile?
Exactly.
Yeah.
Okay.
Have you heard about it?
But what I want you to do is just walk up the stairs and wait for me on the next
floor.
She'll watch a quick,
tell me what it is.
Okay.
Check about the get Jack.
This is not a scary,
scary.
What?
No,
it's just,
it's just key.
What did they try and do?
You'll see.
I see Rosie,
so apparently this is some sort of illusion.
She came downstairs and he was right in there.
Yeah.
How's it an illusion?
I don't know.
I can't figure it out.
They say it.
Look,
it's true.
You can see that it's edited.
That is a flat surface.
It's a first step is a flat scoot ahead to the black to black people are always
best in these things.
Black guys,
black men are the best when it comes to any kind of magic trick or anything like
that.
Look at this guy.
No,
he's holding hands.
Hand.
He's holding hands with everyone.
No,
he's holding.
He's at the stairwell corner.
If you've tricked me into watching a gay porn,
I'm going to be really upset at you.
Okay.
No,
I don't believe that at all.
He went downstairs.
Come on.
What are you stupid?
What's wrong with your brain?
What are you talking about?
You broke,
edited that.
There's no way to edit it.
What are you talking about?
Do you know what fucking they can you ever see Avatar?
Yeah.
That's not real.
Listen,
you listen to this motherfucker.
Did you Google hoax and fucking Google it?
There's no proof.
What's the name of the video?
R.
I.
T.
It's at the Rochester Institute of Technology
hoax and it's a real,
see how the are big girls squirrel illusion.
That's how it works.
Brian,
you guys give it up to each other.
I love it.
Okay.
How does it work?
Well,
it doesn't.
What you're witnessing is the illusion of an illusion.
In short,
the video is a fake you fucking dummies.
This is a variation on a concept called Penn rose stairs created in 1959 which
itself has roots in an illusion created in the 1930s I'll get back to the rit
stairwell in a moment,
but let's trace the evolution of the illusion in 1934 switches,
Swedish graphic designer,
Oscar,
blah.
My questions this don't break.com
created a series of optical illusions that we're all familiar with now created a
series of three d geometric figures that are only possible in two d space,
and not only did he create impossible triangle,
you also created the impossible staircase.
That's how it works right there.
Yeah.
I guess there's a slant and that's a little smart.
Okay.
It's easy.
So you go up,
but you also come down.
Yeah.
And then you go,
dude,
I was fucking,
it's stupid.
Stupid as fuck.
If you looked at mom for building it,
that guy's dumb for building it.
You're dumb for sweetening it.
Everybody's dumb as fuck.
If you looked,
I'm trying to talk to you about big foot problem out there looking for,
okay.
Okay.
Wait.
So wait.
So wait,
so this is,
this was my pitch a long time ago to,
to a network is that I would go find the number one big foot hunter in the
country.
I would give them $50,000 and say,
this is it.
When did you come up with this idea of,
this is true for like eight years ago.
Why didn't they listen?
Yeah.
Uh,
well,
you haven't heard the pension.
Every one of my big pitch and Bob Gay sex and Lacrosse,
every one of my pages suck.
Joe.
The losing team gets fucked in front of the Sasquatch.
I pitched moat crashers to DIY crashers,
right?
Like people have a moat knowing people in America have a moat.
That'd be dope as fuck.
Thank you.
Oh my God.
You being a chick home,
Brian.
Come on.
Think about this.
Brian is the only one single here.
Brian,
think about this.
Give me some,
give me some fucking pimp music and I'm going to paint a picture for you.
I'm going to come home.
I'll lose my mind.
You're going to come home.
Oh Brian,
you take a chick,
you drive her home and you're,
you're,
you're murdered out Ford Suv I with you.
You bring her to a bridge.
You say,
hey baby,
don't be worried because the water is only six feet deep and I'm sure you can
swim.
And the crocodiles,
we feed them every day so it's really more scary to look at,
but a no big deal.
Okay,
we're going to make it across
drawbridge.
And then as you,
as you have them in your murdered out Suv and you're rocking some Mc Chris,
and he'd go,
by the way,
Mc Chris,
he tweeted me once and you casually like show him your phone real quick.
Yeah,
that's an MC Chris tweet.
I saved it in my favorites.
Anyway.
Um,
this is my mode and this is my castle.
I had all this built totally ecofriendly I built it out of assholes.
It's made out of assholes.
It's the most eco friendly house ever.
What's up?
Oh you fuck.
Oh fuck.
Sorry.
I should,
I think would be a good move.
So Mo,
I pitched it,
I pitched it to DIY that they have no one has a moat.
No.
Every,
every key man's house is his castle.
Every castle needs a moat.
I fill in and you moved the fuck out of a house.
I think that's a good idea.
And I think also what's a good idea is not ever needing a moat.
What's the good idea?
Is that the anti moat,
the Anti Kingdom to let people know that somehow or another we have been tricked
into thinking that we need to be in battle with each other for in order for us
to be fruitful and survive and to do well.
And that shit is nonsense.
And the only reason why you need a moat is cause you need
to believe that this sort of feudalist state and this ridiculous society that we
live in is going to maintain the way it is instead of just surrounding yourself
with a gigantic group of loving people and spread that out as much as possible.
That's what I'm saying.
How would a motive love amount of love,
wait,
wait.
Mark Jannis here.
You leaving.
Okay.
Brian was leaving the building.
Ladies and gentlemen,
but worry not,
he will be a live on air,
uh,
at the comedy store tonight.
If you want to listen,
go to d,
uh,
Ustream.
Dot TV.
That's my bad.
You don't do it like,
I mean we recorded it but was just a secret show.
It will air sometime in July of 2016,
11,
11.
Teen muffs heads.
He has on ice.
Fucking try promoting something.
I don't want to Brian's podcast.
Why don't you bring those guys in here?
Um,
bring Kevin.
Kevin needs to come back.
Can for sure.
Yeah.
And maybe we'll bring Ryan,
Kelly and Kevin Together.
That would actually be fun.
That actually would be a fun.
Uh,
it's true,
you know.
Okay.
Desktop promotion show.
Are you really leaving Brian?
That kind of stuff.
He's got to go to work.
We'll still talk bitch.
You don't love me anymore.
Give me some.
Here's,
but here's a,
here's the other idea.
So I find the number one big funder foot hunter in the right.
Okay.
I go up to him.
I say go into his house supplies,
not like publisher clearing house.
Oh,
it's your name.
Uh,
Derek Johnson.
Like who the fuck are you and how'd you get to my house?
And he shoot you in the chest.
But it was Bert Craig Craig style.
See Brian or Jenny Jones style.
Uh,
my name is Bert Kreischer.
I worked for a travel channel.travel channel and a.com.
That's [inaudible] dot com I worked for travel channel and I have $50,000 to
give to the number one,
the number one what?
I got $50,000 to give you the number one big foot hunter to take you on.
You're $50,000 what kind of a budget is that?
That's ridiculous.
I will become the number one big foot under zero fucking contest.
Here we go.
Like 50 k.
I'm very competitive.
Burt Christ want,
I want this guy to have everything at his.
I want him to have everything he needs.
I go,
your trip leaves Sunday morning and he's through the roof.
You got 50 grand for the his passion.
He shuts the door and then I look at the camera and I go,
my trip starts Thursday.
So you're gonna fake bigfoot and I,
but you watched this guy.
The fact you're going to fake bigfoot.
No,
no,
no.
That's the show is watching the number.
What?
Bigfoot hunter find big foot seven times without the camera crews around going
like,
I swear to God,
I saw him.
What if the number one big foot hunter has an internet connection and downloads
this podcast or is listening right now,
eight years ago,
Bert Kreischer,
you weren't the Bert Kreischer of 2013 eight years ago.
Jesus Christ.
Do you have any old jokes that didn't work at the time cause you weren't really
that good at comedy and as you get along and go,
oh that bitch got some sauce to it.
I had a bit that was a real game changer because it would tag my act and I had
to throw it away,
but then as I've done
like three new hours over the last three years,
I get to a point where I started like trying to find some shit like go over my
notes.
Is there anything that I wrote that I missed and I've found some stuff that I
wasn't good enough
to do.
It sucks about these young kids that just go in and know how to do 20 minutes of
murder and aren't writing a bunch of growing up in Boston,
in New York,
you just wrote so much that you had bits that you go look back down when
revisit,
you're like damn
yeah,
it's hard when you start,
when will also,
when you're like trying to like make it as a standup comedian,
there's a real issue where people like you're scared to take any chances so you
lock into a few bits that you have a lot of confidence in and that you've done
many,
many times.
So you're pretty sure that work and it can become a real crutch.
It become a real bad thing for young guys and we,
we know those young guys and have that like 1520 minutes that just crush.
But then we know those sleeper dudes who aren't as attached to crushing as they
are to creating and those early Tripoli,
I swear to God when I watch tripling,
I was going to say Bill Burr,
Bill Burr,
Bill burr too.
But no,
but I love triple it because you didn't take some chances.
He does.
I think he's the guy that every fucking time takes a chance.
Bill burrs bills constantly writing bill was on the podcast.
One of the coolest things that he said,
he was,
um,
talking about,
uh,
creating shit.
He's like,
Dang,
cause I've got a rule.
He goes,
ah,
I'm a,
you know,
I didn't say no.
I have a,
I'm going to come back.
I'm not going to fuck you.
I'm not gonna fuck.
Yeah,
that's,
that's my,
uh,
my agreement.
I come,
I'll have some new material.
I'm not going to fuck you.
How the,
you know,
Tosh said to me one time,
I was like,
God damn,
man,
all your shit's knew.
And I felt like I didn't have it right that much.
And he goes,
well,
yeah,
but you're not in the position in your career where it matters.
Like you should go in and do the best show you can so that they come back next
year and then start complaining and say like,
look,
he goes,
right now I'm at the place where if I don't write a new hour,
they'd feel like they'd gotten ripped off.
You have to definitely write a lot of new shit,
but then people get pissed if you don't do certain classics.
But I always say I'm,
I don't even know how to do them anymore.
Like I've had people yell out Duana Nicole Smith.
I'm like,
listen man,
you could probably do it better than I could do it.
Cause I know when I was a kid,
when I was at like big Sam Kinison Fan,
I could do a Sam Kinison bent.
Like if you,
like,
if I had to like do it for a friend,
I could do it for a friend.
Your writing changed your,
your voice on stage has changed so much since that time.
Yeah.
Well,
I'm a different human being,
you know?
I mean I think it's really silly to try to stick with who you used to be,
Or to be a sort of uh,
uh,
invested and not changing who you are or are not evolving or not adding new
things.
I've seen a lot of people change,
man.
I just know a lot of people change.
I think change is a beautiful thing and I've seen Brian Chanes,
Eddie Bravo has changed the law.
You know,
we had Dan Hardee in here last week and he was talking about his Iowasca
experience.
That was one of the best podcasts I've listened to.
I like,
I like the win.
I think when your podcast is at its best is when you take a guy like GSP or Dan
that I don't,
I don't expect much other than maybe like some UFC conversation or some like
talking about some training stuff or like diet and then I done fucking blown
away by what fascinating.
That's a reason.
It's like Chael Sonnen,
it really defines the UFC fighter in general is that they're not,
they're more renaissance than they are.
This fighting is fighting is,
it's like all school fucking Ernest Hemingway put your dukes up.
Shit.
It's not everywhere.
Yeah,
it's like that Dan Hardee podcasts on the treadmill and I'm fucking googling,
uh,
the Lee Marie Jo.
I swear to God,
I'll get on a fucking plane,
do a fucking visitor with that guy.
He can,
he's in Morocco prison.
You don't want to go to Morocco and visit [inaudible] prison.
They'll check your asshole with a microscope to look for what's chips.
What's the other dude?
Uh,
uh,
Hartnett Harley,
um,
wolf,
goddammit.
The other guy that was fucking just a beast that would sucker punch dudes and,
and uh,
so it was like the second guy you talked about him and then they,
what?
Bronson not,
no,
but like,
but,
but it was when you were talking about an MMA guy and I'm Omega Wolf,
Tiger Wolf,
wolf,
pussy.
Something like that is not full of pussy.
It was,
wow.
I don't know who you're telling.
You might've made some money up,
somebody take medicine then go to sleep.
No,
but I was hung over jogging and I'm,
but Goddamn,
and those two fucking interviews back to back world,
like he knew what it is.
It's like people don't get a chance.
It's very rare that people get a chance to sit down and really talk for like two
plus hours,
three hours.
Yeah.
That time I couldn't,
I had to go with my kids to Disneyland was my daughter's birthday.
And so,
uh,
I had to take her to Disneyland so I could,
we could only do like two hours.
You should have Moen again,
dad for sure he's going to be on because we barely got to his,
uh,
Iowasca experience and everyone,
everybody,
people like,
yeah,
he barely talked
about that.
Yeah,
you're right.
Absolutely.
Like people,
that's,
that,
that were bummed out about that is just because it was,
that's how the conversation went.
And this is something I want people to kind of understand when it comes to
podcasting.
I can,
I sometimes,
yes,
you're right.
Like sometimes like maybe,
um,
things go too much in one direction or not enough in another or one person talks
too much or,
but the emphasis is always on trying to do the best show.
So when you,
if you give like a criticism about that,
believe me,
I listened to that.
And,
um,
it's just Dan's my friend.
So what will you got to see was like me and Dan just shooting the shit and me
trying to get something out of him.
But we,
both of us having like points that we wanted to make and it's conversations like
that,
you know,
and you just sort of were there organically taking place completely naturally
taking place and you have anything planned out,
but just a rough roadmap of where to go.
They don't always wind up,
especially when it's like only going to be a limited amount of time is two
hours.
They don't always wind up,
uh,
where you want them to go or get everything in you want it to.
So that's why I said at the end of that podcast like,
Hey,
we've got to do this again,
like two weeks.
I heard you in the middle of say you go,
I know guys,
I'll get to the Iowa Ska,
but dead honest with you.
I had forgotten about the IOWASCA and I was interested in what you guys were
talking about and that's the way it podcasts at its best should go is just be,
oh,
and I'm telling you dead honestly from a guy who's done radio for fucking eight
years of going in and doing radio and you go in and you definitely Bam,
Bam,
this is not that medium.
This medium is a new thing.
It's almost a,
a new honesty that's uncomfortable as an entertainer.
It is uncomfortable.
It's uncommon.
It's a lot of it is uncomfortable.
It's uncomfortable to present it.
It's uncomfortable to read the criticism.
It's uncomfortable to,
uh,
to try to analyze it and watch it.
But that's also what's really good about it because as much as it's
uncomfortable to be a part of it,
like it's very inspiring.
Podcasts are very inspiring for people.
And even podcasts that aren't necessarily like this kind of podcasts.
Like I always go on and on about hardcore history,
but it's,
cause that's all I've been watching or listening to these days.
All I listened to is Dan Carlin.
Talk about Ma.
I listened to the wrath of the cons no less than four times in a row,
the whole five,
six part series,
five hours,
and I've heard it no less than four times.
You talked to Eddie Wong about that.
Yeah,
but that was a long time ago.
But because you talked about it,
I started watching it about the cons and I was like,
motherfucker,
dude,
the podcasts are amazing.
You can get something for free that's way better than anything you would pay
for.
I love Opie and Anthony and I love Jimmy Norton and if it wasn't for them,
I would cancel serious.
I wouldn't even have it.
I won't even,
I will say though this,
and I've said this to Sam and and,
and rolled into the two guys that worked there.
I just wish I could get opie and Anthony and Howard and Howard and Howard and
Ron,
any tenant and they to Ron fs.
I wish I didn't get them on demand the way I get them on your podcast because
when I get on a plane and I go,
shit,
I forgot to download podcasts,
I go to Stitcher and I just upload one and I and I let it load up and then I
listen for that to take off.
I usually pass out halfway through.
It's still up there to my list and I'll listen to the rest of it.
I don't think there's anything wrong with the way,
like they say they do it in Howard TV or anything wrong with the way they do it
on the opiate Anthony Channel.
But I think they should also do it in a podcast form where you could download
anyone you want at anytime you want and they probably do.
And we're just talking shit.
No,
it's on audible.com and,
and I'm not a big fan.
You don't like audible?
I love audible.
What don't you like about audible?
Who?
I Dunno.
Fuck is wrong with you.
I'm fucking like,
what if they want to advertise with me and it's like money.
I'll be real honest with you.
I don't know.
I got a boat because I heard it so many times.
So like this is fucking awesome.
Greg Fitzsimmons is the guy I used his login.
It turns out you've got to buy points to buy the books.
I don't want to buy the fucking points.
What are you talking about?
The way audible worked from?
From from me and then now I'm not talking a opie and Anthony where you just go
and you buy like for a dollar.
You got their episode,
but audible worked where you had to buy like get 20 it was all on my phone so I
can only speak from my phone,
but it was like,
I was like,
fuck,
I'm going to buy an audible book.
Greg Fitzsimmons talking about,
I don't know Greg at all whenever even met the dude but it,
but I trusted him.
He,
it sounds like actually listens to fucking books.
So I go and I fucking by the points I go on and I go to get the audible account
and I think I'll just go get an audible account and I'll get it.
You got to boy,
let by like 20 points for,
you can sign in with your Amazon account too.
You know I don't have an Amazon account,
dude.
I'm not.
I'm not like super,
no,
I don't like super.
What?
I'm not super technological like that.
That's so easy though.
I know,
but Amazon,
Amazon,
one click is like,
I've used it on so many sites that aren't even Amazon sites.
I don't even know what Amazon one click.
It's not making anything from Amazon.
I'll tell you right now,
Amazon is the shit.
What does am I am grace.
Amazon.
You know why?
Because there's a lot of,
here's,
here's a perfect example.
Billiards and pool.
I play with two different types of cues,
played with a 13 millimeter and sometimes the 12 and three quarters millimeter
depending on how often I'm playing or whether or not I don't want to adjust my
game.
But when I'm looking at a queue,
it's very hard to tell the difference between a 12 and three quarters and the 13
millimeter.
So I buy some fucking calipers,
millimeter calipers and I get them and then I fit it over the tip.
And I know exactly what and then I mark it.
Where the fuck am I going to find that?
If I'm not going to get it on amazon.com I get it on amazon.com is 13 seconds.
I type in millimeter Caliper,
boom.
One Click,
yes please.
Boom,
it sends to my house.
I open it,
boom.
I now I have it.
I have these millimeter calipers.
I will never go against Amazon unless they go evil.
Unless Amazon becomes a tool of of skynet.
Until then
there is something very powerful with with that one click like Uber,
Uber,
Uber's Oss.
I use Uber all the time.
People don't know what Uber Is.
I used Uber
the first time when I was in Manhattan.
It's a credible you.
It's incredible.
You can grate it.
You use a,
it's like a,
you know like a town car or limo or something like that.
More expensive,
more expensive than a taxi,
but way better.
And they pick you up and they're gentlemen and everyone's nice and kind and they
all want to impress you with like how,
what a good service Uber is because the more the better job they do in,
the nicer they are,
the more likely you already
use it to there their Yelp,
it's five star or one star.
I do gave a dude one star one time because I ordered an Uber from my parents and
I was so proud of it and he showed up in a fucking Celica with food in the his
trunk and I went,
wow,
I go,
you're over.
And apparently there's a new thing where you can get on Uber.
You don't have to get a town car,
you can get like a taxis,
crazy creep driving you around with his fucking pizza stewing in the trunk.
No,
you get a town car driver.
He uses his own car and just drives you.
There it is for those people that may not have,
uh,
not,
not that I have a ton of money,
but like for those people that may not have like a ton of money,
but it's,
it's,
it's actually a viable option.
It's a little sketchy if you're a,
if you're a dude,
it's
not a bad deal.
But Celica a little bit of like,
I sound like I just used that name,
whatever the fuck it was,
Sonata or something.
Come on Joe.
You to pick apart by stories.
Funny thing though that you have to look at check as to really worry for a dude.
You know a dude,
it's sketchy,
but it's like no one's trying to fuck you on the normal oh fuck dude into your
house.
Oh yeah.
With the premise,
I want to fuck,
let's just have fun.
This is where I live.
Spend the night here while,
and assuming that the dude is not a Dickhead,
assuming the dude is not going to do something horrible and you know,
that's uh,
being a woman,
that's got to be way harder.
When you hear shit about this kidnapping thing,
he never heard about a guy getting kidnapped for 10 years,
forced him to fuck some check little boy.
So Adam Walsh.
Yeah,
by Dude's kidnapped by dudes.
So not kidnapped by women.
That's what my point is.
It's way harder to be a woman,
you know,
and to deal with men.
Men are creeps that creeps demand and they're creeps to women.
Sometimes.
That is the number one issue with our world.
Conti men.
If we could cut cunty men like Morrissey once said,
it's a really annoying thing.
I've talked about it on say,
I love saying that once.
That's a great way to start a quote.
I even have a joke about it.
He said that,
uh,
that gay,
if,
uh,
fall people were gay,
there wouldn't be any war.
It's like people look at it,
things like that because they think that it's,
but it's,
it has nothing to do with heterosexuality.
Nothing or,
and the contempt is,
theater has nothing to do with heterosexual,
but it does have to do with men.
It has to do with asshole men.
But it doesn't mean that all men are assholes and that's where things get weird.
Like I got in this dispute with a bunch of feminists and uh,
one of the things that I said I was making fun of male feminists because uh,
there's a lot of male feminists that I always,
I liken them to vampire familiars so if they just trying to get close to the
WWE,
they just,
they don't have any appeal with women.
So they like,
they change who they are and adopt for what like really powerful women want won
his battle with you because I saw that go down on Twitter.
But the truth is did you not live enough of a life of a man?
Like as a man where you,
at one point you start saying,
I'm very empathetic to all women's rights.
I have two daughters and a wife.
All my animals are female.
But like I did grow up a boy.
I was a boy in my whole fucking life and I felt what that felt like.
And I will always identify with being a man first and not a woman first.
There are some guys that almost identify with women before they identify with
men.
Yeah,
like I,
well there's a lot of gender traders,
both on the female side and on the men's side.
All these feminist identify with being a women woman.
You're going,
me to a gal that I was dating once said to me,
never trust a girl,
doesn't have any girlfriends.
And I said,
why do you say that?
And she goes,
because,
okay,
every girl knows that guys want to fuck them.
Right?
And I go,
yeah.
and the girls don't want to fuck it.
Right?
And she goes,
yeah.
She goes,
well,
how come they don't like you?
Girls don't like that girl.
She doesn't have any girlfriends.
So it's one or two things have happened.
Either you just moved into town or you fucked everybody's boyfriend.
Shit.
And I just looked at,
I'm like,
this bitch is too smart for me.
I'm an eight,
at least 18% more chimpanzees and dude,
I've got to get outta here.
Fuck you.
I'm a kissing on the cheek,
Ma.
And then the other chick,
Ma,
don't hit me.
I got to go.
That should be a short series Joe Rogan's defining moments
a moment like that.
That was a good one.
Man dropped some serious knowledge on me.
She dropped some serious knowledge on me.
She looked me in the eyes when she said it too.
It's like a really strong move.
She goes,
don't ever trust a girl who doesn't have any girlfriends.
And I remember I seen him cause I,
I remember saying to our goal,
I was like cocky because I was like 24 when she said this.
And I was like,
why?
What the fuck you is say,
you know,
what about,
some girls are assholes and,
and then I just,
you know,
when she,
after she said that,
she's like,
the girls know who you are,
they know who you are.
And I just went,
wow,
I can't even argue with you.
Um,
the only equivalent I have to that,
and I hate to use his name twice in one podcast,
Anthony Bordain put trees.
I fucking wish I chased it.
Beautiful.
Marjorie said to me one night here,
the phone talking to his black dude and we're sitting in the bag of then blow
the Boston comedy club.
We're sitting down,
there's a bench in the corner by the window and we're sitting,
talking,
we're sitting talking and he's watching me the whole time and I just recently
tried to just grow a beard for the first time.
And uh,
we get up,
the guy gets up and he moves.
Patrice sits down next to me was the fuck you doing talking to him.
I said,
what you have?
Don't ever talk to a black man that doesn't have facial hair?
What's this have to do with it?
And he goes,
no man,
fuck you.
Any black man
has a facial hair.
We grew up
so hilarious.
Fucking great.
And then I started bombing around in every black dude.
I knew how to facial hair.
It was like the greatest little fucking.
Meanwhile,
Patrice
didn't even believe that.
He was only saying that because it was the funny thing.
It was a bug with me.
And at the same time he goes,
you got to learn how to trim your lip because I was white guys,
we'll let the hair grow into their lip and black guys don't do that.
Dates up on the lip.
Patrice and I had,
uh,
a couple of cool moments,
but one of the coolest ones was I wasn't even in the room.
I called up opie and Anthony and a w it was Louis and,
uh,
Patrice and uh,
Anthony and opie and Anthony was talking about guns.
Like we're talking about guns and he's,
he,
he worries always about about being attacked and all this different.
And I go,
don't you worry that like maybe your,
your manifesting this with you with your own.
Like if you have reality and you're all focus on that,
you're manifesting an attack and that Patrice goes on.
Joe Rogan see Joe Rogan knows about magic.
And I remember just laughing and I was like,
man,
I can't believe Patrice is goofing on what I just said.
This is beautiful.
It's an honor.
You know what I mean?
It was,
it was a it,
it's like,
I dunno,
I missed the fuck out of that dude.
I remember,
I got to tell you where I was when I found out he died.
He was a fucking,
he was a solid dude,
man.
I remember where it was.
Oh,
is that the,
um,
I was at Rusty's a dog,
a dog store and Jura,
and I was going in to buy food for my dog and frosty called me up and he's like,
trees died.
And I was like,
it was like knocked the wind out of me.
So,
uh,
so I'm in the car with Leanne,
my wife is in the car and I get in and,
um,
uh,
visibly upset and,
and,
and just like,
are you going to go to the funeral?
And I was like,
I don't want to go to the fucking funeral.
Only because all I could hear if I was at Patrice a funeral is Patrice laughing.
One,
I wouldn't go to years,
motherfucker.
So I was like,
I then,
uh,
and I fucking started crying and my wife was like,
what the fuck?
Like
I cried.
I've cried for a few guys.
Yeah.
Do I said what the fuck?
Cause she was like,
she said,
go to the funeral to the funeral food,
this upset.
And I was like,
I go,
no,
because there's no way explained to trees,
to a woman to go,
well,
you know,
to explain to my wife you could.
He's mean,
it's like,
how do you expand Oprah to a dude?
It's enough.
Um,
I cried for Freddy a soda.
I,
my,
I was a hard one man.
I was with my,
if you don't know if Freddy Soto was Freddy Soto is a lost treasure.
This is a few guys that I've met in my life and had like this,
this really undeniable charisma where like if I knew that he was going to be
performing,
I would,
I would find,
you know,
we were outside,
like the comedy store was a weird place where like,
you know,
sometimes a guy would be on stage and you'd like the guy but he didn't want to
watch.
But Freddy,
I would go in,
I mean I wouldn't watch all of his sets.
I didn't watch anybody.
All of their sites cause it was too fun to be outside in the parking lot.
But there was a lot of guys who are going every few months to see what's going
on,
see what's going on with Freddy.
And Freddy always had something going on.
He was always on some new angle.
He was always a developing his delivery.
He was always getting a little sharper.
He's just had a,
a beautiful presence like on stage and knowing the dude from like real life.
We're all a fraternity of Weirdos,
man.
You know,
like standup comedians or if you the worst torture ever for standup comedian
would be no comedians for the rest of your life.
Only accountants.
Only accountants and lawyers forever.
Do you know who?
No kidding.
Just see the number and there's a lot of cool ass accountants and there's a lot
of cool ass lawyers.
But what are the odds that you run on to one of them most likely going to run
into a non cool last accountant,
horror,
boring ass fucking lawyer.
And you're going to get trapped.
A lot of people to go,
whoa buddy.
Yeah.
But if I saw Freddy Loc card,
we could be in Alaska.
You know,
I could run into that dude in the middle of the woods.
I'm like,
Freddy,
what the fuck man?
We'd,
we'd hug each other and then we would be together.
He wasn't going anywhere.
I wasn't going.
I wasn't going anywhere.
He wasn't going.
Nope.
Freddy Soto had the joke.
Uh,
um,
I fucking loved about his dad.
A lot of great,
his joke,
joke,
Freddy Loc or Freddy Soto had a joke about his dad going,
uh,
it's the word that everyone misused that he'd go,
eras,
eras.
It regardless,
regardless,
regardless.
Grabbed the fucking,
like,
it's so funny because you know,
that could be written off as like,
oh,
that's what it's like to be a young Mexican man.
But it's not,
it's like,
it's what it seems to be a young man,
the young man,
and you just saw it painted in his colors.
But I dealt with that with my dad.
But in the same way of your dad being wrong and it was so beautiful.
Such a beautiful joke.
Yeah.
That was where it connected.
I mean,
that's where bill Cosby stuff connected with a lot of white people back when
people weren't listening to the black people talk.
That's really what it was.
It's just that he,
he hit a note that Edd,
it was universal.
Yeah.
You know,
and what you saw was,
hey look,
we all grew up.
I mean everybody grew up either everybody's alive today,
either grew up in pushing it as the forties it's the fifties sixties seventies
eighties nineties and two thousands that's it.
And most likely the older you are,
most likely the older,
the older you are,
the dumb or your parents were when they raised here.
Yeah.
Because people were just dumb or them.
And you can't blame them.
They grew,
we imitate our atmosphere and we adapt to our environment.
And if we grow up in a place where no one knows what the fuck is going on,
it's easy to lie.
You have your family's caught up in religious calls and the other half of your
family is fucking crazy.
And who knows how to live this life.
Who knows,
who knows what they're the correct way to go about it.
Not enough information is being exchanged back and forth,
which in the forties fifties sixties seventies 80s and nineties it's not until
the two thousands come along that people start like looking around and going,
what's happening here?
This is a brief moment in history,
man.
It's uh,
a couple of decades where at least we're trying to make sense of things.
There was no effort to try to make sense of things in the 60s and the 50s they
didn't have the resources,
they didn't have the access.
Occasionally you got groups like the Communist Party would come along and all
they would do,
they would propose an alternative way of life.
And then a,
like Joseph McCarthy would come along and arrest anybody,
went to meetings and then everybody abandoned all that shit at a fear.
And then we move on to the,
the next stage.
And then the 60s someone came along with acid and the acid came along and all of
a sudden for the first time,
so people grew up with some bullshit buddy Holly,
you know,
than done the nonsense music of the 1950s were indoctrinated into the world of
psychedelic drugs.
And then that changed.
So that was the first wave of information.
The first wave of information wasn't the Internet.
It wasn't even books.
It was psychedelics.
Psychedelics.
After books,
books laid a foundation and then in the late fifties early sixties Albert
Hoffman came along and boom,
and the universe gave the human beings a big kiss on the lips and then all of a
sudden,
boom,
we blossom with unique ideas and the Western world,
the height of intellectual debate and stimulation was introduced to the most
powerful psychedelic drugs known to man.
And it all branched out and flooded from there.
And then from those came the very idea of the Internet.
How many people that that did that created the Internet didn't smoke weed?
How many of them hadn't tried mushrooms?
How many of them never tried it?
Man,
the Internet without you might be able to.
I don't know.
I don't know how your brain works.
I don't know how you can,
do you know who you are?
I don't.
I you don't know how to do who I am.
Can you imagine if you had to be me for a day?
Whether or not you would do it without fucking it up.
I couldn't be you for a day.
If I came home and I tried to be you and your wife would be like,
what the fuck is wrong with you Bert?
Is she checking for Robbie?
I was like,
go.
Okay,
what we'll do,
we'll it Burt too.
It's not that easy.
I could not be you.
You could be me in a heartbeat.
No,
he's saying that
now.
You say that that's not true.
I could never be painting.
I can never be my sister.
I can never,
it doesn't mean that each individual unit is like,
it's more or less effective.
It's like I would be less effective at being Bert.
You know what I'm saying?
Like
I see what you're saying,
but like I definitely like if like if it was like freaky Friday and we
[inaudible] wife swap,
I would be like,
I'd be like,
I would be,
I would be the mom who got the child's body as opposed to the child.
Like in the Lindsay Lohan,
Jamie,
Jamie Curtis movie.
There was a movie with Lindsay Lohan and Jamie Curtis who was like,
Lindsay Lohan learned a lot,
but she not fun.
Jamie Curtis have fun but did end learn a lot.
They both learned a lot.
I guess that's the point of the fucking movie,
Curtis.
Okay.
I'm looking for that is ridiculous.
I want to have Jamie Lee Curtis like gets mad when the pizza delivery guy asked
her about that.
Holy Shit.
Freaky Friday.
You did freaky Friday.
It's like bitch,
I did the original Halloween fucking freaky Friday.
She,
uh,
we had,
um,
you know the rumors about her that she's a hermaphrodite.
Yeah.
What's that rumor about?
A douchey rumor?
Sweet.
So I had,
I did a show for comedy central long time ago called buzz where we'd,
it was Ben Bailey show cash cab,
but with drunk people.
So pay people about three toms Grover was the head writer and I picked people
off the street and then we play a game show in the back of a van and a randomly,
last group we got was a bunch of like three dudes that were fucking hammered.
The mount you blew into the breathalyzer was your bank.
So if you blew the dude who was the drunkest who was like,
you just add a zero.
So if you bought blue 0.36,
you got a $360 in the bank just for going home and being responsible.
Then every game we played,
you could accrue money,
so could bounce with like 750 bucks for the group and we'll drop you off at home
and you just made money in [inaudible] stupid fucking show.
Are you involved in,
it was a lot of money.
So,
uh,
so,
so with the Lens of fear factor host,
sorry.
So we last dudes,
we picked up,
we said it was game Tom and created called liquor stick it.
We put a picture of a girl and you've got to guess if she's straight or gay.
Licorice stick it.
And so like,
like three pictures of girls that are innocuous like pink and everyone's got it.
You know,
and like just short,
just short haired girls,
you know,
that,
that they may not know who they are,
but then the handgun.
Yeah,
ambiguous.
I'm sorry,
I'm not innocuous.
Fine.
I'm like knock ewas vacuous.
So one of them is Jamie Lee Curtis and the guy goes and they all say lick it and
then this one kid goes,
no,
stick it.
My Dad fucked her.
And we're like,
what?
And he was,
my dad fucked her.
I think I'd go,
but I heard she's a hermaphrodite because my dad never said that.
But then again,
what dad's gonna say to his son,
he fucked a dude.
You know,
that's a really bad Freudian slip because innocuous means like not dangerous or
offensive and ambiguous means don't pay me enough and not do it.
And knock us is like,
hey,
you know she,
she ain't even taking a dick and not a lot of it knock us women that don't count
in my book because she might be sucking cock.
I was in not a Freudian slip,
it was just me being dumb.
Yeah.
Innocuous is a beautiful word.
Get off correctly.
If you can pull it off people like half my life is spent saying some real really
does just say it's the worst one that's ever come out of your mouth.
So that you went,
Ooh,
I said,
uh,
did the nail stage in Portland.
I said,
I was explaining a joke and I said,
I was explaining to my daughter the tenements of comedy and someone goes,
you mean tenants?
Well,
10 minutes of word.
I Said said apartment building.
Yeah,
I did.
I got a better one.
I said,
I did.
I took a movie pitch out for like fucking literally 10 before someone stopped me
goes,
I think you're using the term a salt of the earth wrong.
I thought salt of the earth was like,
dude,
that just hang around all the time.
So I was like,
I was like,
this guy grew up with the salt of the earth.
That's the type of person that sold you the earth means like the really good
people.
Great.
I just thought it meant people that hung out and were like,
you know,
like you know the dudes that were always on the corner of the salt of the earth.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Why did you think that?
You just like heard the expression and never investigated Joe?
At one time I gave a speech,
I thought the word,
I thought idiot savant was synonymous with autistic and I said to my boss,
I said to my,
well,
for a lot of folks it is,
but an ironman.
I thought what I was trying to say is my buddy is really good when it comes to
meeting people I met say like he's the idiot savant of meeting people.
You don't need to even be just does it,
but I see you said the autistic I go,
he is autistic.
When it comes to meeting with people and people were like,
oh fuck,
you're using that role and I was giving a speech in front of like 500 dudes,
artists,
autism and being autistic is very unfortunate.
It's actually the direct opposite of meeting people sometimes.
Sometimes,
but if someone is artistic and also a savant,
then it's like,
oh,
he's emotionally troubled,
but look at the great blank.
He does idiots.
Silvana is,
I don't even know if that's politically correct.
I don't know what I'm saying.
No,
there's nothing wrong with an idiot some lot,
but it's like,
it's like when it comes to math,
it becomes naturally and they're so good at it.
They're amazing.
Right?
So I was trying to say it.
No,
no,
no.
It's not just that.
It's the idea that they're not good at anything else.
It's like you take a guy that could barely communicate with you,
but then you put them on a piano when he makes amazing music.
That's an idiot savant.
So it,
it's to bond.
This guy's a terrible way to,
to express it because it's clearly someone who has a troubled brain function or
a troubled mental function,
whatever,
however you want to describe it.
And they also have,
um,
a lot of energy floating around.
And sometimes if they can focus it,
whether it's on art or whether it's on music or whether it's on whatever it is,
you know,
uh,
it could be video games,
it could be a game,
it could be something that intrigues them,
that
math,
whatever it is.
Absolutely.
Math,
music,
dancing.
And when that happens,
then they find an outlet for that intense focus.
Because they're there,
right?
Because the fact that they're limited in various social arenas,
limited in their understanding of human communication,
they might not put any resources to that at all.
They,
one of the awkward aspects of who they are might be that they don't put any
resources to that.
They just have blocked that out.
So instead they can concentrate almost entirely on trying something or making a
mute.
A song.
Right.
Yeah.
Well I would have used it wrong if I said it that way too.
I meant to say it was really good at it.
So I,
I chose idiot savant.
No,
no there's nothing wrong with saying idiot savant.
Even as a goof on your friends.
Cause saying like,
cause we all know that guy that's not good
at one thing,
but he's,
you know,
or he's not good at a lot of things.
But this is one thing and he's fucking awesome APP.
You know,
whether he's an awesome mechanic or he's an awesome musician or an awesome
comedian.
I mean how many comedians that we know that are absolutely hilarious.
But if Joey Diaz had a function in the real world,
you can't tell me Julie Diaz is not an idiot savant for standup comedy and not,
and that by saying he's an idiot savant.
I would never say he's an idiot because he's a brilliant person.
When it comes to recognize what's funny about something.
Yeah,
he's got a true genius perspective when it comes to that,
but if we give,
Joey had to work in a factory next to you,
you'd be hating your life except for the fact that the stories would be awesome.
Love it.
Work next to him.
He'd probably love it.
Although you were picking up his job,
the company would only love it if they could enjoy his personality,
but if the company had to rely on its productivity,
they'd be fucked.
The Real Kenny powers,
he's better than that.
Better than that,
but it's like,
it's like,
yeah,
that's a character.
He's the real deal.
He's just doesn't fuck around a kind of version of that.
Yeah.
That side sort of a hyper,
c'mon,
what are we doing here guys?
The Guy,
the guy who comes up with his own way of handling the situation that she ever,
do you ever watch Sean rouse do standup comedy show?
I Love Shaun.
What's he up to,
man?
He's got a lot of physical problems.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
he's got a lot of,
he's got real bad arthritis.
I man,
he was fucking talented.
Yes.
So fucking talented and he's a beautiful,
I was thinking idiot savant.
Like he's almost like,
it's like that person now.
He's actually a good comic.
You Fuck No.
But his personality,
so like if you put him in a workplace,
there's no like,
like there's no dialing that back maybe,
you know?
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't know what kind of jobs he's had his hand up.
It's,
it's hard to do anything but stand up a bunch of,
you're good at stand up because everything else,
it seems so boring.
You ever play that game?
Imagine if you had another job.
I have other jobs,
so I try to keep other jobs like UFC and podcasts.
That's saying no,
not a job.
Job.
Take rules from a guy named Derek.
That's work.
Yeah.
That is not fun.
Who's like I said,
10 o'clock it's 10 oh five work at ups checking boxes in the back of a truck.
I,
I see those dudes that listen to these podcasts and the color and they're like,
man,
you guys doing that podcast makes my life so fucking doable.
And you think to yourself,
what a fucking service you get to delivered to like a guy just like yourself.
Exactly.
Shelf.
I just,
for me,
I can say just like me because I just got lucky and really stone wrote an
article about me.
Right?
So like I,
yeah,
but that's all bullshit.
I know.
But it was a doorway that opened up that allowed you to be bird.
You know,
we all got lucky at one point in time.
I got lucky that a friend talked me into going on stage at an open mic night in
1988 and we were all got lucky in one way or another.
But from there on,
it's really just about,
and this is a really important thing for other people to realize.
Like people,
I,
we've had this discussion on the podcast before and people like,
Oh,
you're just counting luck.
Absolutely not.
There's unquestionably the fact that you're even alive is incredibly fortunate.
If you look at children that have progeria,
if you look at people that are born in terrible places in the world,
just the fact that you're in America,
you have to concede to a certain amount of luck in this life.
There's no doubt about it.
But I'm from then on,
what allowed you to move forward and what allowed you to advance yourself to a
position where you're really comfortable creating comedy on stage?
It's not a lot of luck.
I mean there's sometimes locked pops up,
but you know when it comes,
when you actually have done work,
if you're going to be a comedian,
if you're going to be a performer,
if you're going to be someone who people,
there's going to be some amount of talent and work that's involved there.
It can't just be luck.
And so to concentrate on the luck of others is a very negative way of focusing
on things.
And it doesn't inspire you because it seems so random and unfair.
You know when you look at a guy who named the Guy Blank,
this guy all of a sudden has got you selling out arenas and he sells a million
CD's and why him?
And he got lucky and if it wasn't for this,
this lucky fuck,
and you're doing a disservice to yourself by focusing on that,
there's that shouldn't even exist to you.
Well you should do is say,
wow,
look at what's possible.
Look at what's possible.
If you're this guy,
look at what's possible.
That's incredible and it should make you instead of like shitting on this guy
instead of like,
oh Kevin Hart or all the fucking knew
Ken Young,
someone who can cook like that.
You would,
that you would let people go.
No.
Cause he's hilarious.
He's amazing.
I'm not,
I didn't mean Ken.
Ken,
don't hear that and think I said that,
but I,
but I know what you're saying when you go like he was just a harder,
better example really.
I think Kevin's fucking so talented,
talented people.
But people will question there.
Oh,
it's got to be lucky.
I've heard,
I've heard it so many times and you get lucky.
It's not possible.
So you just say it because it didn't happen to them and they think that this guy
got picked somehow that he figured his way through.
People find a way to justify their continence.
Yeah.
Cause I,
I understand.
I mean I think Kevin Young,
Kevin Hart,
I just don't have forever.
I think he's super talented and,
and even Ken Young,
but,
but the only argument I would give with,
with like Ken was at,
he's a movie star and he got into a movie that happened to blow the fuck up.
Like people could argue Zach's very lucky.
I think Zach's very talented,
just like Ken.
Like they just happened to gotten to be into the biggest movie of this
generation.
Yeah.
The hangovers dub good.
Exactly.
But I'm saying that's how people could argue.
Luck.
We
all know the god that wasn't that good sort of snuck into things.
And then after awhile people figuring them out or they get better.
I mean those are the only that are available.
Either they get better or people figure him out and they they,
they fade away.
Yeah,
but that's just this weird ass fucking stupid business.
It's business is super unhealthy.
I say that.
I would say so that La is like a methadone clinic for attention whores.
Like you never really get cured.
You just get hooked on some new shit.
You just get hooked on some acting shit or some popularity shit.
We're having kids.
Yeah.
Some people,
well,
yes,
I saw it.
It definitely does it.
We had to do like,
uh,
an hour long.
Are we getting close?
Yeah,
we're on,
but five minutes away.
Do we turn into a pumpkin fuck three hour podcasts.
All right,
let's wrap this rock this.
It's kind of comfortable now that Brian's not here.
It's unfortunate for him.
Brian's listening,
listening to shit.
That lazy bitch will never hear this.
Let somebody tweets it to him.
He texted me and he goes,
you can download opie and Anthony.
Yeah.
You were talking nonsense about audible.com one of our sponsors.
Are they really?
One of your sponsors,
but it's okay.
I mean you should be able to express yourself.
You're like,
ah,
points and Amazon.
I don't sign up for that.
Yeah,
it's me.
It's,
it's dated.
I was also the guy in college and they were like,
listen,
or our assignment today is to email your paper to us.
And I was like,
ah,
this is never going to last.
I don't know why we're learning this.
They were also the guy that pissed on his father-in-laws dining room table.
Yeah,
I shit on a pizza box to win an election.
But you've,
you've evolved past that,
past that completely.
How you constantly working on yourself,
Bert Kreischer what is your message for the folks of America that are listening
right now or England or Ireland or China or wherever the fuck they are?
My question is,
uh,
just be honest.
That's a good move.
It's my only thing was stages.
I,
I'm getting in trouble with it a little bit.
Just be
trouble.
Never heard nobody.
Bert Kreischer just trust me.
And on that note,
go fuck yourselves.
Ladies and gentlemen.
I say that with all due love and respect,
what are you going to do?
My podcast whenever we'll work it out.
We'll figure it out as soon as I pay.
Thanks to squarespace.com thanks to squares.
Now you don't want none of that is thanks to Squirt,
squirt burt.com no Squarespace,
excuse me.
Dot Com go to squarespace.com forward slash Joe and use the code Joe Five and
save yourself some cash.
Sheesh,
some lovely Dallas on a beautiful website distribution type creation type site
getting there.
We're also sponsored by stamps.com thank you to stamps.com go to stamps.com and
click on the microphone in the upper right hand corner of the site and entering
the code word j r e for your hundred and $10 special law for including a free
digital scale.
Then I say that,
come on your fucks.
We're also sponsored by [inaudible] DOT com if you go to Rogan dot ting duck
calm,
you can save yourself $25 off either service or a new phone.
It's an awesome company,
a beautiful sight.
It is a set up wonderfully to use and both Brian and I use the surface and we
vouch for it.
Go to rogan.ting.com on at.com oh and and it forever.
And always one of our sponsors.
Why is that?
Because I'm a part of on it on it is a company that is completely created around
things that are Bree and myself think will benefit human beings.
As far as your physical performance,
your mental health,
your physical stamina.
No,
we don't have big Dick Pills,
but if you want to find those,
go to death squad.
That's fine.
Quarter that Marcus hooked on the why.
Agora,
that poor.
Fuck.
All right folks,
I'm,
I'm searching for bigfoot,
so I'll see you soon.
I will be back.
Most likely.
We're going to do a weekend podcast.
I'm like Saturday or Sunday.
So until then,
peace,
love and grenades.
Jihad love you.
All.
Big kisses,
hugs for the world.
MTMA would cure it off.
Everybody needs to go on one acid trip.
Now,
not everybody.
Maybe a mushroom trip.
No,
maybe Mbma maybe ecstasy it together.
Bitches love you guys.